hey everyone this is shruti from simply
learn welcome to this video on the
digital marketing full course for 2021.
in this full course we'll be covering
topics like what is digital marketing
the tools used in digital marketing the
basic concepts on seo google tag manager
google ads social media marketing
facebook ads youtube instagram and
twitter marketing content marketing
email marketing affiliate marketing
marketing hacks digital marketing skills
careers and much more
for this video we have our experts rob
and rahul taking us through all the
topics so without further ado let's
start by talking about digital marketing
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it
first joey learnt that digital marketing
was a form of marketing through which
you could advertise to people digitally
digital marketing leveraged different
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails and mobile
applications it would give marketers the
opportunity to interact with and
understand their audience better and to
increase the trust in their brand
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to people based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought
there were also many types of digital
marketing types like content marketing
search engine optimization pay-per-click
social media marketing email marketing
and affiliate marketing and once he
understood those types he set up a
digital marketing campaign for his
uncle's e-commerce website let's have a
look at what he came up with first joey
created content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies so that he
could generate audience interest in the
brand's products or services
this was content marketing next he
needed his audience to actually see his
content the first step was to create
content on specific search keywords that
were relevant to the target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results by
continuous optimizations joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was seo or search
engine optimization and joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also drive traffic to the
website with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked he could have text ads that show
up in search engine results image ads
and video ads that show up in websites
and much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing joey
realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
help them better understand the products
they visited on the website and assist
them in the buying process he would also
send emails to advertise his products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although joey was able to grow the
brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third party websites
this could be achieved with affiliate
marketing affiliates would promote the
brand or product to their audiences for
a fee with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through
the wait although joey had worked really
hard on each of these forms of digital
marketing he only had moderate success
that's when joey realized he had to gain
more knowledge and experience
so he decided to get certified and get
ahead in his career with the help of
simplylearn he took up simplylearn's
digital marketing certification and got
the skills and training he needed to
become an expert digital marketer and
now you know where he is
you too can do the same and grow in your
career by clicking on the top right
corner and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of digital marketing greetings everyone
this is rob sanders and today we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing so thanks for joining us here
at simply learn and let's get started
let's start talking about why digital
marketing is important so let's start
there on the why so
we're just a fly on the wall and we're
in an office environment we're looking
at two friends having a conversation
about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digit marketing has become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you basically
create a thousand flyers okay you figure
it's going to a thousand people maybe
they'll share it so you're looking about
2 000 people maybe just to be generous
well digital marketing we're promoting
an event we can promote it to a whole
lot of people depending on the platform
so 2000 is nothing when you're targeting
an audience on facebook or google search
traditional marketing
non-versatile and with digital marketing
very versatile so again going back to
our flyer printing an eight and a half
by eleven okay that's it you know with
with digital marketing you're running
display banners you have 468 by 60 200
by 200 250 by 250 300 by 300 i mean the
list goes on on the types of different
display sizes not to mention text ads
not to mention video or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
go to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we could see
real-time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend so
that to me is one of the biggest
advantages to digital marketing not only
do you get real-time results but you can
control costs and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of cost
you're spending based on those real-time
results with traditional marketing it's
difficult to reach a target audience you
know with digital marketing it's easy to
reach a target audience i mean you know
i don't want to bash traditional
marketing too much i mean if you're
going to put a tv ad in place you know
you're going to do it on a tv show that
tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device when we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go and promote our
product or service using a campaign we
have different options so there are
different types of digital marketing
channels that we can choose from and
let's just go through that list of
digital marketing channels and the first
one is what i consider the king of them
all and that's seo so seo stands for
search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including google so depending on where
you're located in the us market google
ten or has a large market share so you
want your pages on your website to be
found and clicked on organically and so
that means that somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're going to
get to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword you don't have to worry
about organic if you're willing to pay
for it you just bid on that keyword and
voila you have the opportunity to appear
number one in the search results at the
top of the page for that keyword now
when somebody clicks on it you have to
pay google if it's google you're
advertising on but that's the beauty of
search engine marketing you can bid on
keywords and appear at the top of the
search results for that keyword example
here if we go back to online shopping
well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to a hundred dollars it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you could
send your emails to a segmented audience
okay so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part
has a functioning email account
so basically here's an example
you're selling a product
and the products promotion is about to
end well you know get that email out to
your target audience let them know hey
you have until tonight to purchase the
product and if you purchase it you're
gonna get 30 off and you can put the
coupon code right in there with a nice
call to action and you can measure how
many people click on that email go to
that web page and purchase the product
using that coupon code so that's an
example of email marketing okay we have
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is an effective way for
digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
commission junction or cg.com as an
example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me
it's a good way to you know really
promote your product or service and you
can pick and choose the affiliates or
the publishers of whom you want to work
with so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12 advertising fees with
a trusted e-commerce leader okay so if
somebody clicked on that and purchased
for example or joined you could pay off
that commission okay let's turn our
attention to social media marketing so
social media marketing you know i would
say it's fairly new i mean if i think
about it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you can
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an
infographic or it could be an image okay
there are lots of ways to create content
these days especially in digital
marketing and the great thing about
content marketing is you're writing
content for a targeted audience so
if you're trying to targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example
you can use basically sms or instant
messaging via mobile devices to promote
your product or service here's another
example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service
via mobile marketing okay let's talk
about the customer life cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to net we want we know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling or what we're
promoting okay so the awareness stage is
really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
gonna become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide okay
those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is it gonna help
me in my life okay and who who is
selling this i mean who is this brand i
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see it when they
do a search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found and so to me this is you
know where the blog comes in seo take
that content get it optimized okay sem
if we're not ranking organically we can
make sure we're at the top of the paid
search results or the the search results
for a particular keyword we want to be
found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training
like simply learn does you know linkedin
is a good platform for us okay and then
affiliate you know basically building up
a nice network of publishers to get the
word out so these are all good channels
that we can focus in on so traffic
sources may include paid unpaid social
referral display email or direct so they
they could come in the awareness stage
from all different types of channels
even though you're focused on content i
mean you could still get traffic from
mobile or email so now that we got the
word out via all these different
marketing channels there's that
consideration stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you gotta create
something really snazzy or really it's
gonna be attention-grabbing or something
that's gonna get them to become aware of
it that's gonna separate your posts from
all the other posts that are in
somebody's facebook newsfeed okay so you
really have to work hard to really
convince somebody to get their
consideration towards your product or
service so in this stage your customer
considers your product so help them
understand how your product is valuable
okay to me email works really good here
because if you have a targeted audience
this gives you the opportunity to really
answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display
i think display is a good option here
too because even though you know people
are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really get them to take that next
step okay with display you can even do
remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them via display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here okay so you have email
mobile display you know sem these are
all you know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you and now we're on
to the purchase stage so the questions
we want to really make sure we address
here are how are my prices compared to
my competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to
tell customers and that that is hey i
have a good brand i have a good product
i have a good service come buy my stuff
come buy my product and service but you
really need to support that claim you
just can't go out and say it and so
supporting that comes in the form of
what other people say and that could be
reviews that could be comments on a
social media platform it could be you
know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence and make sure
you get people to
you know review you or provide
testimonials because people are going to
do their due diligence before they
purchase especially if it's on google my
business or yelp or trip advisor or
whatever it is you're trying to sell
they're going to be able to see those
reviews and so do your due diligence to
get the reviews and if it is a negative
review hey that's okay you can't please
everyone you're gonna get them that's
the world we live in just make sure you
show your upper hand and respond even to
the negative as well as the positive
reviews that you get that actually bodes
well to some people because hey it shows
that i made a mistake and you're willing
to correct it and so people actually see
that that could be the tipping point to
getting them to purchase hey look hey
this brand really cares because they're
really responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20 percent and email's a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of people through sms okay social media
reaching people instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives pro prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to
not push a product on your customer but
think about how you can complement that
purchases that purchasers or customers
product and then how to improve the
customer buying experience
so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice channel
you send in a nice message even you know
social media
you know you can thank your community
for supporting you on this recent
campaign that you ran you know even
throwing an extra five or ten percent on
a future purchase is a thank you and
that's easily done on social media
you know you could even post a blog you
know
promoting you know the success of a
product
and then offering a promotion okay so
there's a lot of things you could be
doing here on the post purchasing stage
so to me even looking at content again
you could even you know put a survey
together you could even put a survey
together for your affiliates okay you
could even post a poll on facebook so
it's just working in with these
different channels to get some feedback
about your product and service so with
email mobile you can engage customers
with follow-up emails or customer care
content you know with mobile if you have
somebody's mobile number hey text them a
simple thank you goes a long way you
know you could say hey look if you're
satisfied let us know give us a call you
can even in the ee mobile text message
you can put a link to a survey send
emails to active subscribers give
rewards for customer feedback so if
somebody does provide feedback give them
an extra 10 off you know you want to be
able to reward loyalty
loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10
i'm going to go ahead and purchase from
these guys again so give those discounts
to those active customers or on the
affiliate network give referral
opportunities to your customers so if
it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
purse purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale a cross sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage today
we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019 but ones that have performed
well in the past that are popular and
ones that we foresee as being the go-to
tools for the future so past present and
future digital marketing tools is the
way to look at this uh with a good focus
on a lot of different marketing channels
here so we're gonna focus first on seo
talk about some of the tools related to
on page and off page we're going to
switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it
in fact if there's a tool that we didn't
mention in today's webinar feel free to
mention it in the comment box below this
video we'd love to hear what you're
using to manage your particular digital
marketing channel okay and so the goal
for today's webinar is hey we hope you
get something out of this in terms of
using new tools there's some tools that
i use some tools that my colleagues use
everybody uses different tools so it'd
be good to kind of see what else is out
there so if you have something to share
share it by all means what we're trying
to do is share what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most popular or most used
tools out there in the industry so
that's what we're going to do the goal
is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization or organic
search we have a mixture of paid and
free so there's a lot of different
platforms but if you're focusing on seo
you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyboard planner and
if you know anything about seo you'll
know that using google's keyword planner
is a good tool so we'll take a look at
that moz is a freemium tool meaning they
have a free trial that you can sign up
for to test drive it but it's another
seo platform and it does cost money got
a great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
gonna hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense
so we need a tool to kind of help us put
it all together and so the tool of
choice for us is google's keyword
planner and google's keyword planner
helps us hone in on keywords we may be
interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here meal delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i can say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another keyword if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword in other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here
i get a
column for competition
so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
seven dollars and forty six cents and at
the top of the page high range sixteen
dollars and sixty one cents so that
should alert me to the fact that hey if
i'm gonna try and optimize for this
keyword i know it's competitive because
not only google is telling me it's
competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is
highly competitive
so the idea here using google's keyword
planner is one we want to get an idea of
what other keywords are out there that
are relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably gonna take me a bit longer
to be found for this keyword on page one
of google so that's the whole idea
behind google's keyword planner and note
that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer shorter period of time you
can even choose a specific location so i
chose taxes i can certainly choose the
entire united states to get a sense of
what the volume would be for the total
u.s so you have settings that you can
change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively i can certainly use
another tool to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask maz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from 11
and a half thousand to 30 000 on monthly
volume now what maz does is they give
you a difficulty score so a difficulty
score is a score between 1 and 100 and
so i could see this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's if it's a hundred it's
very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis uh related to
the keyword you know they also give you
some good keyword suggestions so moz is
a good alternative tool and we'll be
coming back to moz related to seo for
some other of its features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
google's keyword planner because maybe
you're not running google ads you can
always use mazda remember moz
has basically a freemium version meaning
you can sign up for a free account and
you can sign up for a free account as a
test trial and you could test it for a
period of days and leverage its tools
during that free trial to get a better
sense of how these tools work so we want
to be able to use mods we want to be
able to use google's keyword planner not
only to search for all those relevant
keywords available to you but we want to
be able to choose keywords with high
volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice portfolio
of diverse relevant keywords with high
search volume and low difficulty and
then you want to be able to identify
those keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so moz gives you that
information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this we got a nice
webinar on keyword research for seo so
take a look at that video on youtube and
to get more specific details about using
seo tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
seo so let's talk about some other
reasons under seo what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic hrefs again moz let's take a
look at google search console and i want
to hone in on google search console
because it is free and it's a must if
you're going to work on seo you need to
be working in google search console and
so the whole key behind google search
console is you have a website and you
need to get that site verified once it's
verified when school can recognize that
you are
associated with this website
then you're going to be able to see
some important information so
here i'm looking at a website and what
am i looking at i'm looking at something
called coverage under index so what does
coverage mean well going back to what we
just said we want to be able to
understand how google's crawling and
indexing our pages and so what google
does is through this platform search
console is they're letting us know once
they go to our website and start
crawling it and they pull these pages
back to their server they're letting us
know
if we actually have any issues so here i
can see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
4-4
you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i can
see submitted url marked new index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you fall victim to this error and
so we can really hone in
what the error is and address the error
okay so if google's telling us hey this
is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
so these are the errors i could see they
certainly were able to crawl and index
pages they were able to crawl okay and
they excluded 54 000 plus pages and then
we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done
what google's going to do is say hey
look we see you've submitted this and we
last read it a couple days ago and we
could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they've discovered via the
sitemap and so the whole point of a
sitemap is we want to be able to get and
push the urls to google not have google
come to our site and discover them so
this is a quicker faster more efficient
way to communicate with google all the
urls that you have on your site that you
want google to index and so that's the
beauty of search console now while we're
in search console we might as well take
a look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand
how your site fares
via mobile and when i say fares via
mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards and so if there are any issues
google is going to let you know what
those issues are so here i could see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read click
elements too close together the viewport
not set to device width and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if i
actually click on it the error i can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
google telling google look i see what
the issues are i'm gonna fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey
we do recognize the errors we are fixing
the errors please validate them you know
it's going to draw google's attention
google's going to validate them and get
these pages indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search consoles shows
us what pages have the most links okay
so here we can see the home page has 26
000 plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so externally
i want links from other websites
pointing to various pages on my site and
i certainly want my pages linking to one
another on my site and so i'll be able
to better understand what that structure
looks like using google search console's
links report okay there's one more
report that i think's of interest in
google search console and that's the
performance report so the performance
report is a report that actually you can
link up with google analytics so you can
see the same report and analytics if
you're able to link up google search
console with analytics and you should be
able to do that all you need to do is
make sure you use the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address you could certainly link up the
two
and have this data imported into google
analytics so what is this data that
we're talking about well it's called
performance so what we can actually see
is the queries the actual queries people
are typing in to google so when they're
typing them into google we can actually
see
how many impressions the keyword queries
received and how many clicks the keyword
queries received and then i can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here i can see
for this particular keyword on the first
line i could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
209 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result
of somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times this site received 120 000
plus clicks so to get a sense of the
click-through rate all you need to do
and google can obviously do this for you
is you would simply just divide the
209 000 297 into the 120 000 397 okay so
that's really going to give you that's
going to give you a click-through rate
and the click-through rate in this case
is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many impressions and
clicks i'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
i can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now i
mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
google search console and then from
there you can choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so i can
see the same data that i see in search
console but this time i'm looking at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my impressions my click-to-rate bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and nofollow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we can certainly
see where they rank the great thing
about moz is it's a great tool not only
for rankings and on-page optimization
but
for off-page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here as i keep going down for
example i can see this particular
website has a domain authority of 26 and
it has a spam score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has
so many links pointing to me or it has
at least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority
spam etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page seo so that's
the great thing about moz is they have
not only on-page seo tools but off-page
seo tools and moz is a freemium so to
speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about
with using some of the tools google's
keyword planner
uh moz and google search console okay
let's switch over to email marketing
tools and so with email marketing tools
we have a lot available to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available
you know marcato is a good tool you know
marcato is a good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning they
sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social
to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma
you know feel free to to note that in
the comment section below this video i'm
curious as to how many people actually
use you know different tools because
there are so literally so many email
marketing tools out there why because
email marketing has been around probably
the longest amongst all the other
digital marketing channels and a lot of
people use email on on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you could certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of recipients clicked on your email what
links do they click on you know which
which emails bounce so you want some
detailed insights right in the platform
that you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create that
smart automated campaigns meaning you
don't even have to send out the email
and then you want to be able to have
some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time and
day so these tools also allow you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or are you going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to you know pick and
choose who we're sending this to who
it's from what the subject line is and
then we can certainly
design the email so if we click design
email again this is important because
with email marketing you want to be able
to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer
so you know here you can see there's
some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
lists
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so here i could see
this email that was sent out in june i
could see it was sent to 95 000 plus
subscribers okay of the subscribers i
saw 2000 plus open it and 157 clicks so
i can view this report in more detail
just by clicking on view report so again
we want an email platform that's going
to be able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so i can get down
really to the nitty gritty i can
actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here so if i click
view report i can specifically see what
the average for this list is so here i'm
able to compare against the list average
and it's 16
i only had an open rate of 2.5
so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you can link it within
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products
and somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example if i have a url
that says visit florida and i'm going to
send out an email i have up to five
parameters that i can use okay so here's
my email or url that i'm using in the
email so i have up to five parameters
that i can use to track this particular
email so let's go through some of those
parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
mail champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lower case so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's going to get
subject line one and one segment that's
gonna get subject line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is
in the campaign content field so now i
have four parameters and once i've
entered in my variables in those
parameter fields i now have a revised
repented url so my original url was
visit florida.com
ian-us
florida-beaches.htm
my original url i've now appended that
with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with
my utm parameters appended to the url so
that's for the first subject line that's
for the audience that's going to get the
first subject line i want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
i'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore two
i'm going to copy that url i'm going to
check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line 2 so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm going to use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
send out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we can start with source
and medium so if i click on source and
medium as my primary dimension here i
can see
mailchimp and the actual date was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i can i see the medium being
email so now i can see for this email
that was sent out in mailchimp in may i
could see how many users how many
sessions and more importantly how many
conversions so we could certainly hone
in on that particular email if we wanted
to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see
what subject lines from my emails
generated the most traffic and not only
the most traffic but also conversions so
that's the whole point behind using the
url builder again you're taking a url
that you're going to use in email and
then you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're gonna get
an appended url which you can then use
in your email so when the email gets
sent you're gonna go back over to google
analytics and you're going to look at
the results of that campaign of that
source of that medium of that content
i.e subject line and so that's why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates
but what we really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with google analytics google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is
part of google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well
again we want to really measure behavior
we want to measure what's going on with
our website so we want to be able to
identify the location of where our
website visitors are coming from and a
lot of these analytics tools use ip
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
50 new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around
and improve performance so if your
bounce rate is high well how do you
lower bounce rate well we need to do
something about that and analytics tools
will help us identify what's not working
from our site perspective and from a
channel perspective and we can take
action to improve performance so that's
the whole idea behind optimizing our
site's performance so let's jump into
google analytics and let's take a look
at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning user so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
to demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 of my
traffic and again this is year to date
that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so i'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well i can
also look at geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
i go to location under geo i'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
i can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here i can see
united states is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17 from
the us and then 16 from argentina 13
from mexico 10 from india so we have a
nice mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i could see
year to date i can see 62 percent are
coming from desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey
from mobile and that is growing
and that's going to continue to grow so
you want to keep an eye on mobile so to
me this is one of the more important
reports under audience because people
who come from mobile have a different
not only experience because the website
should be responsive to the mobile
device but their mindset is going to be
different they're actively looking for
something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we can see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how that traffic
actually got to the site so if we're
talking about a search engine did they
come to the site via paid search or do
they come to the site via organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and media and we
could see specifically the breakout of
the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site so here i
can see google organic at 71 percent and
then google cpc or cost per click at 15
of our traffic so then i can look down i
could see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources of mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns all campaigns
and we'll be able to see the campaign
performance if we look at source and
media we'll be able to see what
campaigns drove traffic to the website
so here i can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so
that's the campaign reporting and then
also if you have search consoles so we
looked at search console earlier we
talked about seo tools well remember i
said you can link up search console with
google analytics well here's search
console and we could see queries devices
landing pages countries so all the
performance metrics that we could see in
search console because we have it linked
up with analytics we can see it right
here so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're going to get so that's
the idea behind it we want to make sure
that we're ranking for our coveted
keywords and if we are we want to be
able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
google search console and google ads you
can connect them directly to google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so
here in behavior
we have a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions
so i can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page
and didn't go any further they left the
website from that page that they arrived
on and so i can also see percentage of
exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page not
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because paige isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so when we load up the
speed suggestions report what google
does is say hey we know that this page
is loading very slow the average page
load time is 15 seconds here's some
suggestions we're going to give you
seven suggestions so if you click on
that what's actually going to happen is
you're going to go to another tool
called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see if i
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that i can
address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift and page load time
we see lift and page load time we're
going to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me site speed
is an important report under behavior
now one more report here that i want to
point out under behavior is events and
to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here
we could see for our particular website
we have categories already set up for
event tracking so here for example i can
see on line six video i could see how
many people actually watched our video
okay so here's the action video start
okay so over this period of time i could
see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always report to
label and that will tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category an action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so i'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button
downloaded a pdf uh submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because
we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if i go
to admin down at the bottom and then i
go to goals i could see that i have four
different types of goals that i can use
now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold type so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter signups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the donate now button
i could see that i could see
year-to-date ten thousand eight hundred
eighty seven users which meant eleven
thousand sessions 76 clicked on that
donate now button and that comes out to
0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior
and conversions so a lot of data in
google analytics but you want to be able
to take advantage of the data in order
to improve website performance now let's
jump over to youtube analytics because
if you have videos on youtube if you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your video is
performing and so here i could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the beta the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and
i've netted 48 subscribers and this is
an overall okay so i can actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published and here i'm
looking at you know total views over
this particular date range i can also
see specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here i
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here i could
see 25 came within youtube itself i
could see how many times a video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so i could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here i could see
externally how people were able to find
my videos and i could see 46 percent
found it via google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so i could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
i was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times i saw it
and watched it here i can click on
interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partners playlist
with the top playlist so i can see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
youtube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here i can see 88
percent of the people who watched my
videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the
ways in which people found the video
okay again externally or via youtube
search i could see how many people liked
it or disliked it i could see all sorts
of information on a particular video
itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you wanna hone in on
how your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spying tools very
important to keep tabs on what the
competition's doing and there are a lot
of tools out there so when it comes to
social we can use a freemium tool like
sprout social to listen in on our
competitors we can use another freemium
tool social blade there's a popular tool
out there called spyfu that's freemium
as well
moz we looked at moz earlier for keyword
and organic moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because seo organic search is a long
term strategy on page off page website
very technical and creative there's a
lot going on with seo a lot going on and
sometimes it takes a long time to rank
for something and a lot of seo does
depend on relevancy relevancy being how
many quality backlinks are linked to you
so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you stack up and so that's why
this is up there as number one we want
to be able to really take a look at what
our competitors are doing another
example would be hey how much uh traffic
a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competition is doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with sprout social
and sprout social is a tool i use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
posts that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example rv rentals in twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about rv rentals so we could do this for
twitter we could do it facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword rv rentals now if i
want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so rv share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay i can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
i can scroll down and i can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and i can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so to me it just
gives me a sense in this particular
example on twitter as to what our
competitors doing okay let's turn our
attention to seo so remember that first
bullet point we want to get a sense of
what our competitors are doing when it
comes to backlinks and so moz has a
great tool called link explorer and link
explorer there allows us to actually
compare link profiles so for my domain i
can go ahead and put my competitors
domains in there and definitely get a
sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a comparison
across my domain and my competitors
domains to get a snapshot of how i
compare against my competitors so this
gives me an overview of everything i
need to know organically now moz also
has a another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain authority and page
authority then you know i want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them i want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so i can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and then i can find opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see
where
my site intersects with their site and
if it doesn't actually intersect then i
have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under moz's
link explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so
really within mods we can get a good
snapshot of what websites are linking to
our competitors we get a good snapshot
of the overall links to our competitor
sites and specifically with sites so the
whole idea is if it's good for our
competitors meaning they're linking from
a site that has good domain authority
and low spam score then it's probably a
site i want to be able to tackle as well
okay so you have discovered and lost
okay you have comparing link profiles
and you have link intersect so those are
three good reports you can leverage
right in moz's link explorer tool now
there's one more report we can leverage
in moz and that's the inbound links
report and so we can go ahead and type
in our competitors domain here and again
we can get a snapshot of what their
domain authority is page authority for
the home page but really this is what
we're after linking domains so this
particular domain has over 9 000 linking
domains so what we can do is actually go
through and see
based on domain authority i could sort
by domain authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here i can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking new york times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9 000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url
is linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on reddit
then we probably need to be on reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so
inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitor is doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay i can see
here the keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so this particular domain has been
around a long time okay so that's on the
organic side flip over to the paid side
and i could see that they are doing paid
search i could see 5 000 plus keywords
they're bidding on okay based on that
what they're actually paying and then i
could see you know some of the other
competitors listed here from a paid
perspective and an organic perspective i
could see the shared keyword overlap
okay now again you can pay for this
because it's freemium and get some
really good insights as to how your
domain compares to your competitors so
i'm using the free version and here the
free version spyfu is just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
i entered in and so i entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at google ads history i could
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then i can see some organic ranking
history here as i keep scrolling down
this overview report so i can see for rv
rent where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic wise and so spy food
is a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if i hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and i hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that i get then i could see hey
analytics in this case in this example
sharing 8
863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and i can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how i stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and
we can adjust our locale and if we do
that google is going to be able to
adjust how many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with the 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so if we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i could see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site
size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some good insight as to what
the competitors are doing and you don't
want to use a tool well look no further
you can always go to google.com okay so
this is how we used to do it back in the
day before all these tools became
available you just typed in a keyword
and we're going to type in rv rentals
and now we're going to be able to see
who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rental so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now i could see i have 163 000 results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have 163 000 different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a 100 impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or are competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position i can see how often
i overlap with my competitors okay i
could see how often i'm above a
particular competitor i could see what
percentage i'm at the top of the page
versus my competitors the absolute top
of page rate and then i can see how
often i outrank my competitors and vice
versa how often my competitors outrank
me so i could see all this good insight
as to what competitors are bidding on
the same keywords i am okay so this is
if you're running google ads okay so if
you're running google ads okay you can
just click on the auction insights
report you can find them the top
navigation just by clicking on campaigns
and by doing so you'll be able to gain
some insights as to where you stack up
from a paid search perspective against
your competitors so let's turn our
attention to paid marketing tools so if
you're doing some advertising on google
bing linkedin you probably want to work
within those platforms as the tool of
choice so
you know if you're doing paid search
on say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so
wordstream is a third-party tool that
you can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well
we want to be able to monitor how our
ads performing so which ad receives the
most traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that because we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information in the case of auction
insights as to how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so
that's on the paid search side then you
have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example avril okay curtillo celtra
is another paid version or paid tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and write customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that
and that's on the display side and if we
look at social okay why what tools can
we use on social well you got facebook
ads manager okay you got ad espresso
quiet
tweepy you got all these cool paid
search tools again i usually stick with
where i'm advertising so if i'm
advertising on linkedin or twitter i'm
gonna leverage that platform but just
know that there are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights
in this example about facebook users how
are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly so let's jump right into
google ads and look at some tools
available to us
from the search side of the house so if
we're running search campaigns right in
google ads we could see campaign data we
could see keyword data we could see ad
data so for example if i want to see
what ads are performing i'm just going
to click on my ads and extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i could see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads
platform itself now if i want to look at
specific keywords i can do that so i
could see what keywords are driving
traffic and clicks here i could just
sort by clicks and now i can see not
only what keywords are driving clicks i
could see what the click-through rate is
i can see the impressions how many
people actually viewed my ad after click
typing in a keyword query that i'm
bidding on i could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality score
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some other features available to me here
so here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see a search terms report and
so when it comes to search terms i can
actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or i
want my ad shown for then i can go ahead
and just select it and i can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in google ads
okay and then you have the auction
insights so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what their overlap rate is position
above rate top of page absolute top of
page right now rank and share so once we
have google has data then they'll be
able to share that information with you
okay so that's just keywords but there's
a cool tool that i really like and i
leverage it for seo and pay-per-click
and that's google's keyword planner so
if you click on tools and then you click
on keyword planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword
they're going to let me know the
competition they're going to give me a
range in terms of how much i can expect
to pay for that keyword so if i happen
to click on that keyword i can add it to
a plan and then once i've added to a
plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay so
now once i've added my keyword to that
plan i can go ahead
and
see
how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversion set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mentioned this is
one of our key defining why would we use
it bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google eyes
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and if i see
a particular location i'm not interested
in advertising well i can always select
it and i can always just pause it or
remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i could see the ad
groups here okay so for example i just
want to turn off all these ad groups i
can just highlight them all and just
click status enable to pause and i can
revert back if i want to okay so you can
make household changes so here i could
see the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
key words and again i can make changes
at nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick right in google as
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so
if i say get recent changes to all
campaigns what google editor is going to
do is contact google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here i
can see the changes being downloaded in
editor from google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
right in editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you can do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
network as well as for the display
network right in google ads so if i want
to take a look at a campaign and ad
group on the display network i could
just click on that ad group and i can
look at the ads that are running for
that particular ad group on the display
network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search network you can only
use text ads so here i can look at image
ads and i can see how they're performing
in fact you could even go a step further
and use responsive display ads so google
has responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click the rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
display network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i can
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i can see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on google ads okay
so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up on youtube okay
if you search for google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do
then you can see just how powerful it is
and all the different features that are
available so take a look at the video
it's a nice complementary video to this
one this digital marketing tools and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network
then feel free to comment below this
video happy to hear your comments about
what tools and reports and features you
specifically use in google ads so let's
move into uh facebook ads manager and
show you how the platform looks when
you're running ads on facebook so we can
look at all the different tools and
reports available here so here we can
see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and i can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now i can go
in and i can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to
my expectation so if i click on more
tools and then creatives i can just
simply click on creators and then i can
actually see the create is i actually
have running for that campaign i
selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has
reap different reporting so if i click
on the reports pull down menu you can
see here i can see some standard reports
by add ad set age and gender
and then i can see all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device time of day country etc so if we
just look at age and gender we'll be
able to get a breakout age and gender
here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i can see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i can see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad a lot they're probably going to
tune out to it so that's what makes the
frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see how much we spent so this just gives
you some idea of the type of reporting
that's available in facebook ads manager
now the great thing about facebook uh
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup
my dimensions if i needed to i could
change the view and arrange columns i
can get rid of columns just as you would
in google ads reporting very similar
stature here so i have a lot of
flexibility here on how i review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you can pick and choose as
well okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports on how your campaigns are
performing now here i can pick and
choose
i can choose campaign ad set ads
objective again i can choose different
demographics so i have a lot of options
available to me in terms of how i want
to
you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set
a lot of
your decisions are gonna be made
including how you wanna drive the
traffic okay what your budget is okay
you can basically choose your audience
here so you're gonna be able to choose
what type of campaign is going to be and
based on the campaign you're going to go
ahead and choose the kind of audience
you want to focus in on you're going to
be able to choose the location the age
range the gender so all of this is going
to be set up in the ad set or the
campaign or the ad if you go ahead and
edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj you as a merchant or you
as a publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning cj helps
bridge the gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so cj
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track
certain metrics okay so an affiliate
marketing you have earnings per click
epc as an example most platforms measure
epc from a seven day period to a three
month period okay you can also figure
out what the actual cost per click is
just like you do on say google search
you can actually measure that in
affiliate okay you want to eliminate
fraudulent clicks impressions and
conversions so any affiliate platform
worth its weight is going to help you
understand you know how many impressions
and clicks and conversions you're
getting and help you manage that in
terms of fraudulent clicks or hey if
you're getting a lot of impressions and
no clicks that's a problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on a product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see the
different program turns we have set up
for certain publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher's performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole the idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here
we can't or these publishers can't make
any money if they don't generate clicks
so that's why you have an epc model or
metric so to speak so you can measure
earnings per click cj does it over seven
day period and over a three month period
so you could sort based on seven day or
three month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so
here we could see canada and so we have
our publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get publishers you want
to start building your base of
publishers because the more publishers
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's going to
buy your product so if you have
publishers who are promoting your
product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has so
many tools available so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here
you you basically a base account and
then uh you can use hootsuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffers a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweetdeck
it's been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're gonna take a look at
that here in a couple minutes okay and
then you got sprout social sprout social
is another social marketing platform
similar to hootsuite do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout cholesterol today
as well before we do that let's go over
why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you could manage
everything one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one twitter account
but multiple twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own
metrics if you will so for example
facebook has something called facebook
insight so you'll be able to actually
see you know what's been posted based on
you know the last seven days in this
example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so
i don't have to log into facebook
directly i can see you know the
impressions the engagement the clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth i can see my publishing
behavior how often my publishing i can
see the top post individually i could
see impressions by day you know a lot of
this same material same information is
already in facebook insights so if it's
available on facebook insights you know
you're definitely going to have it
available in a tool like sprout social
so you want to be able to just
efficiently log in and jump from one
platform to the other so here you know i
can go to instagram you know and look at
instagram data or i can look at twitter
information so you want to be able to
efficiently jump from one platform to
the other using in this example sprout
social now as i mentioned as part of one
of the benefits of a social media tool
is that you can publish content you want
to be able to publish content because
you want to be able to organize and
schedule accordingly you don't want to
be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose
select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so you want
to be able to schedule accordingly
because again when you schedule
something then you want to look at the
behavior of it so it's just as simple as
going from publishing to reporting and
then based on when something got
published you could see the reaction of
it and react to it so another thing here
that i like about it's about social
hootsuite a lot of these other platforms
do it really well you got listening
tools so you can listen in on
conversations that are being had for
example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location or radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout socials
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account
so i can pick and choose the profile
that i want to publish to so it just
makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
could see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform is
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach a lot profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i wanted to i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions comments saves etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see
how many times the hashtags been used or
saved how many impressions it's received
okay so they really go into some nice
detail here about how your post and how
your accounts are performing and here's
a tool i really like i've been using for
a long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter uh
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
could see the you got the cricket world
cup you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweetdeck it serves
up a interesting overview so to speak of
not only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social later.com you
know facebook insights so it does cover
in more detail some of what we covered
on these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing tools digital
marketing tools everything from seo to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video seo for
example so vid iq you know we want to
use vid iq to get a good sense of how a
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube you can see vid iq
is a browser extension or browser a
plugin if you will so i can go and take
a look at a specific specific video and
see how many hours it's been watched how
many views minutes watch subscribers etc
you know the great thing here i can look
at the entire entire account so i can
get good insights into my video or my
entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing seo and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool
maybe a third party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized
to the fullest according to you know
google's algorithms and so you maybe you
know want to invest in that third-party
tool so these are good tools to use for
content optimization you know there's
also other key reddit but you know
there's keyboard planner uh in google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a google ads platform
and so if you don't have google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
google's keyword planner so having a
third party keyword tool will pay
dividends and so well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
zarget okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with a
free account you can have hotjar measure
the heat map not only the heat map but
the click mapping the scrolling of a
particular page and so here you can see
we're looking at a particular page here
so
hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i can see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking
mostly if i switch over to move mode
then i can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
mouse and then i have my scroll analysis
so i could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to ten thousand page views
with the free version you can measure up
to two thousand pages and so two
thousand page use allows you to get some
insight as to what people are clicking
on or where they're moving or how
they're scrolling on a particular page
and so i definitely recommend hot jar
they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool i would recommend as well so one
final tool and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention it and that's google optimize so
google optimize is a google platform
that allows you to a b test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see i have
an account set up and optimize you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go into reporting here google
optimize does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but you know to me google
optimize is free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests then that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so google optimize is a
tool that i would recommend
carl has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is seo to solve this
issue i have a few important tracking
factors that carl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well
before we get started with the ranking
factors let me first explain what seo is
seo is the practice of getting traffic
from organic search results on a search
engine like google bing etc depending
upon the keywords search engines rank
websites based on what content they
consider most relevant to users
without further ado let me tell you the
top 5 ranking factors which can help
karl to rank his website
first is content quality then it's page
speed of a web page after that it's
website structure
next is ssl certificates
and finally it's backlinks which is the
most important ranking factor let's have
a look at good content quality
a good content quality is an essential
factor that helps a website to rank on
google google ranks content that
completely answers a user's query
in our case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction
this article on the best vanilla cake
i've ever had is a good example of
having a comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include lsi keywords in your content
in seo lsi stands for latent semantic
indexing they're used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serves an easy way to look for lsi
keywords is on google serve some of the
lsi keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link equity across the site
it is important to create a simple
internal website link structure
in the below example a bot crawls on web
page 2 by following internal link of the
web page 1. next add suitable images
with descriptive alt text here using
relevant images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your webpage is completely
crawlable for bots as it will enhance
website ranking
here as you see this website is high up
on the google serp because every web
page in it is crawlable by ports
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience
for a mobile friendly design always
prefer short and crisp sentences for
easy reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile friendly designs are shown here
and most importantly update the content
regularly by doing this search engine
rearranges your site's ranking
for example the sally's baking addiction
cake recipe blog ranks at number one on
google the reason it updates content
regularly
next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a paid
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
paid speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of etiquette memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
[Music]
next use a content distribution network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content at multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code minify
files if your website has numerous css
and javascript file you can minify and
combine them
google sees slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and url
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and url is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe carl cake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and callcake.com is
the brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
[Music]
now talking about urls always refer a
well-structured short and simple url
according to backlinko analysis short
urls tend to rank better than long urls
moving on to our fourth ranking factor
let's talk about ssl certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost in rankings https
is used for secure communication over a
computer network
as you can see here google confirms
https as one of the ranking factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling dns sec protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture
the famous digital marketer neil patel
says the better your site structure the
better your chance of ranking higher in
the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
bots to find and index all of the web
page
a good site structure results in good
use experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are
creating a logical hierarchy structure
which means a good site architecture not
only makes content easier to find but
also helps to gain traffic
[Music]
include site maps so that the bots can
easily access and index the content
code your site navigation in css or html
because these two languages are easy to
code and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last ranking factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
authority
in seo the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
linkedin etc
participating in high pr q a sites like
quora and post answers to the questions
related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using seo and seo is
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of seo so
let's get right to it and talk about why
seo so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and you're curious why am
i not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and
your blog post isn't loading fast enough
well if you look at it this way think
about it if you're google would you
really want to rank a website or blog
post in this example number one on
google rankings if that particular page
loaded very slow no you wouldn't because
when somebody clicked on that link in
organic search and went to your website
they're going to have a bad experience
because the page is going to load slow
so google doesn't want their users to
have a bad experience you don't want
your users to have a bad experience and
so that's why web page load time is a
critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure that our web pages load
fast and then your user experience is
not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is de-indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice clean blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank the those pages that they've
indexed from number one to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spidering but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i could see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to cross simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going to appear in
the search results
so in the example i gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their pages the page load time is
fast meaning these pages load very fast
for the end user and google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in india the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the united
states why because google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google in india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
google search engines in india and
united states google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in seo keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example of how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that appear for
both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30
per month on average and so what i want
to do is get a more clear picture of the
competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when i do that
i get a different result here i can see
only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see
i typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all in
title syntax and now i can see every
listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax hall
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again
you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description
up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely gonna have a good user experience
after they click on the listing so the
url is an element that helps not only
with the click-through rate but with
ranking and having a poor url structure
doesn't help at all because not only
does google
not recognize the url as being relevant
but the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember uh
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end user experience and
it's about allowing google to find the
pages on your website so they can crawl
them and index them so you can be ranked
for them and so also in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords
and the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element on page
seo is the sitemap and so with the
sitemap it's basically a list of all the
pages on your website and the whole idea
of listing all the pages on your website
in one document is it helps both users
and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of site maps one's an html
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that site map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml
just as an example i'm going to get this
particular page and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these site
maps are there for google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind seo you want to be able to
have google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page seo which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on-page or off-page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page seo and so off-page seo is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember i talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking for off-page seo we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
website's recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page seo synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialists on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off-page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website linked back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you could share your content
with them they can share their content
with you and generally that's how it
works naturally anyway in the websphere
if somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents are quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo you know what is on page
seo what is off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one to two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
seo and off-page seo then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly search
engine optimization starts with the
keyword because we want to be found for
relevant keywords and so the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well process
of identifying keywords we want to be
found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
f based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really
the underlying factor here is that all
keywords in your keyword research should
be relevant so you need to understand
what those keywords are so are they
relevant to the content that you want to
be found for if they are then really the
two factors you want to look for is the
volume how much volume or traffic each
keyword has associated with it and then
the competition how many other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and there are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally
have very high search volume that means
that if somebody types in italian
restaurants then there's going to be a
large amount of volume with that meaning
that generally a lot of people type in
the keyword italian restaurants however
with high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because there
are probably a lot of websites who are
in front of you who want to be ranked
and found for the same keyword
so the whole idea with short tail
keywords is it's a lot of visibility
it's a lot of traffic a lot of volume
but also a lot of competition and
generally the underlying factor here is
that if you are ranked for a very broad
or short tail keyword like italian
restaurants then chances are it's not
going to be as relevant so if you get
the traffic to your website then chances
are the conversion's not necessarily
going to happen because we don't
necessarily know the mindset of somebody
typing in a very short tail generic
keyword like italian restaurants they
could be doing research on italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances of
the conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with italian restaurants so
i'm going to go to
a tool called moz and well moz has a
tool called the keyword explorer and
within moz so if you go to moz.com and
then use the keyword explorer you can
get an idea of how much volume and
competition are associated with a
particular keyword so in this example
we're using italian restaurants it's a
very broad keyword we could see that the
monthly volume is between 70 000 and 118
000 per month okay so that means for a
particular keyword in the united states
on a search engine you're going to get
about 70 000 to 118 000 people who type
in that keyword and so if we were to
look at the difficulty of that keyword
you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of 1 to 100 it's got to score 43 so it's
fairly difficult however if you notice
the click-through rate's very high so
moz estimates that we'll have a 40
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to
longer tail keywords however if you want
the visibility
then you want to use short tail keywords
if you want the conversion then you want
to switch over to longer tail keywords
so longer tail keywords are more
specific they usually consist of more
than three keywords so italian
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high case in
point so if we go back to moz and then
we look at the keyword explorer and we'd
actually type in italian restaurants and
let's just say
orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you can see very very little search
volume in fact so little volume there's
11 to 50 okay so that means on average
that this keyword generates 11 to 50
queries a month so very low compared to
our short tail keyword italian
restaurants the difficulty here didn't
necessarily lessen but it is less uh
competitive so if you're interested in
conversions and you have an italian
restaurant in say orlando florida then
this is the key word you may want to use
so there's a trade-off between longer
tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in italian in florida
branded shoes in florida something very
specific is going to generate probably a
higher conversion rate than something
more generic so that's the trade-off and
so when to use long tail keywords well
we want to use long tail keywords if
we're targeting pages with a product or
specific article so if we're interested
in that particular conversion then
longer tail keywords are likely more the
way we want to go versus something more
generic which means if you're using a
generic shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
when you're setting up your brand and
you need to make sure it reaches the
right audience and provide the best
results there's really only one place to
turn to it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising so we're
going to start out with what are google
ads well google ads used to be called
google adwords and it's been around a
good while almost 20 years now so really
google has grown at a really rapid pace
it's become one of google's main sources
of revenue uh you could say probably in
the 90 percentile of its revenue comes
from google ads and when we say google
ads we mean people who pay for
advertising on google.com so google ads
really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you
may also may hear google ads or ppc
referred to as cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model so when you
advertise on google.com and somebody
clicks on your ad basically you're
paying google for they click okay so
it's just really a business model where
an advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement on google.com but they
only pay google when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers if i want to
advertise my business i can go to google
ads and say google place my ad on
google.com and then my ad does get shown
on google.com somebody clicks on it it's
just as simple as i pay google a fee so
google ads is just an online advertising
platform developed by google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved
there's obviously mobile's involved so
you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm gonna be
able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ads
gonna show up somebody clicks on it you
pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic and return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day in fact here
in the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 you search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly
measure our performance so with google
we're paying cost per click and so based
on that model you know we can certainly
measure what keywords what ads are
generating traffic to the website and
how much we're paying for that okay and
if that traffic turns out to be a lead
we can measure that against that
specific keyword or ad or campaign so we
can certainly measure our performance
all the way down the keyboard level and
can we measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has very
flexible options in terms of advertising
and we're going to talk about some of
those as we move along here today so
another big benefit here and this is
what i always suggest is if you're not
ranking organically then you might want
to consider google ads because as we
shown here in our example if i go back
to our example a couple minutes ago you
know if you want to bid on the keyword
what are google ads why would you bid on
that well it's relevant to your business
maybe you're in the digital marketing
industry and you want to help folks who
need help and advertising on google ads
but what if you want to be found for
that organically well if you're not
found for it organically then you can
bid on it so it definitely is a good
option if you're not ranking for
particular keyword organically so it
serves as almost an option i always say
that you know search is like a fruit
bowl okay you have apples and oranges in
that fruit bowl well the orange is
organic search and the apple is paid
search they're different approaches but
they share the same fruit bowl the same
real estate so you can really really
help yourself by using google ads to
complement what you're doing organically
so if you're not ranked organically for
keyword you can certainly use google ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a highly competitive industry
then you can use google ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that ad so it's okay
to be organically listed and have a paid
search listing at the same time so if we
go back to our example here we could see
wordstream.com has a paid ad and here we
can see just two spots below organically
they're showing up with an organic
listing so you could certainly be in
both positions to try and maximize your
clicks so it's definitely a good
strategy to run with google ads on top
of everything we mentioned in terms of
measurement flexibility google ads does
offer up a really good incentive to
advertise and let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when i say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones on
ear headphones those are all site link
extensions meaning they're going to link
to something on your website and so the
purpose of the extension is to help get
the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're going to pay
google for the click but that's the
whole purpose is to generate the click
from search because remember search is
there to respond to somebody's need or
query and so if you get the click on
your ad chances are it's going to be a
highly relevant visitor to your website
so google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on google for google.com so
google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let google do the
heavy lifting why not let google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so
468 by 60 250 by 250 160 by 600 all
these are pixel sizes so you have a lot
of different size variations when you
run image ads okay so you don't have to
run a small image ad let's just say in
comparison to facebook where you have a
thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google owns youtube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on youtube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
youtube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on youtube so the other
ad format you have on google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they could
see the brand and so it's an opportunity
for you to really drive high quality
traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if i go to google search and i
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here i could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names i could see the
price point if i hover over it i can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so if i actually click on this ad
chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also appears under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with google
you also have call ads so when we say
call ads really call only ads are great
for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com
or all google search engines for that
matter so if you want to advertise to a
mass audience you want to probably start
with google.com because again millions
of people use it on a daily basis and so
if you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query
they're going to see results now
depending on the device as well so they
could be on mobile or on desktop they
could see sponsored ads or paid ads they
could see local listings and they could
see organic search results so for
example this is what an ad would look
like so let me show you what that looks
like on google search so if we go for
example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo ad here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and i could see simply learn
using some other extensions with the ad
now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions
in order to get the click okay so that's
the whole idea behind being on google
search if you're on google search you
have the opportunity to be at the very
top of the search result or in the top
three above local listings and above
organic results now if i change my
search query and typed in coffee in san
francisco my search results are gonna be
completely different i'm gonna see local
listings here okay so this is tied to
google my business not google ads okay
so this is completely different so don't
don't mix this up with running ads on
google search so google my business is
tied to local listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely google local
listings above organic results okay and
if i go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing i'm gonna
be able to see paid search results above
local and organic listings so in other
words if you're running ads ads are
going to trump any other type of result
on google search if you can be in
positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign
in google ads you have the option to
choose google search as your network and
then as an alternative or an additional
option you can advertise on google
search partner sites and so some of
their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to
show ads on their site so the sites can
range anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example it could even be another
search engine so if i go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but i can see the same ad for
simply learn so i can see same i could
see a different headline here actually
but i can see the description and i can
see some site link extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see
multiple companies running
advertisements why because i could see
ad next to it and i could see those over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that google or other sites that google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the newyorktimes.com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on google's
display network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so
retargeting as we said earlier is really
reaching out to people who have already
been to your website and didn't perform
a particular function that you wanted
them to perform meaning somebody came to
your website from paid search on
google.com and they went to page a and
then they left so you really wanted them
to go to page b add a product to a
shopping cart and check out and purchase
that product however if they didn't do
that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and page b and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on google's display network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics so google's ads has all the
information you need so let's actually
take a look at some of these options in
google ads for the display network so if
i actually go to google ads and i
actually go to display campaigns i can
see i have a lot of different options
available to me so if i click on
keywords for example okay i can choose
keywords for my display campaign so what
google does if you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually place your ad
based on the keyword okay so that's an
option for you if you're not sure what
websites to be on with the display
network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much i'm paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am i
getting so i could see all this data
available to me in google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance imagine it's the year 2004
this is phil
phil's looking to release a book and set
up a blog
he's sure that he'd be successful but
he's only worried about one thing
he doesn't know how to ensure that his
book reaches the right target audience
who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads billboards
radio direct mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved
now let's have a look at the same
scenario in the present day alongside
traditional forms of advertising phil
would have access to digital marketing
the form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails etc among
these types social media marketing cop
feels eye social media marketing would
give phil the opportunity to take
advantage of social media platforms to
advertisers content to a highly targeted
audience it would help more people learn
about his book increase the interaction
with his audience it's relatively
inexpensive unless he goes into
advertising and will help him get
marketplace insights that might help in
understanding his audience preferences
better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text
they also have a call to action that
encourages user interaction phil could
use images from his book advertised
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads
phil could use video ads that feature
favorable reviews and customer
testimonials to advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more
and in time phil began to see an
increase in the number of viewers coming
to his social media page and by
extension his blog
he also saw an increase in the number of
people who bought his book greatly
increasing his audience here are some
things he learned one to set goals that
were quantitative smart and follow a
constant deadline two to understand his
audience by engaging and connecting with
them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
four
using tools like buzzsumo ifttt buffer
and more for lead generation creating
email lists setting buyer personas and
more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos
but how did phil get so good at social
media marketing
phil had taken up simplylearn's digital
marketing course it was thanks to this
course that phil had the skills and
training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too
by clicking on the top right corner
and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today i mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton i mean those were the ways to get
your product and message out there a lot
of advertising in those yellow pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise vfx just a few
decades ago so these were all the ways
in which people had to get their product
and service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service and engage with
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're gonna answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
gonna be how to start with social media
marketing so you can rise above the rest
leveraging this great platform that we
all take advantage of today so let's
start by asking the question what is
social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to
increase your brand awareness and it has
other marketing goals you know so you
can create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
by viral is spreading like wildfire one
user sending it to another as rapidly as
can be and before you know it you get
you know millions of views and millions
of likes i mean that's the power of
social media marketing so why do we want
to do social media marketing and i think
we just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel
social media marketing allows us to
really put our brand in a good light in
a good position in front of the right
eyeballs so it allows us to really
improve our brand by pushing out the
appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see at every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase we can certainly leverage
social media marketing for seo for
search engine rankings it's about
off-page seo it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working seo and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on twitter or facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say google or bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by
your target audience okay your target
audience goes from seeing your brand for
the first time to getting to know your
brand a little bit more to maybe buying
a product or service from your brand
then returning to buy another product
and service and then continuing to buy
that product or service i mean that's
increasing the top funnel traffic and
not just the traffic but the conversions
so at every step in the process social
media allows you to build that funnel
depending on where somebody is whether
they're seeing your brand for the first
time or actually returning to purchase
the product or service again so that's
the inherent benefit these are the
inherent benefits of social media
marketing today we are going to talk
about all the different ads that
facebook has to offer so introduced back
in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to
share your product and your brand with
users who you think are going to buy
your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's new feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so i
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27 billion in the
third quarter of 2018 and so when we say
spend a lot of time we mean going to
that facebook profile at least once a
day okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout
the day checking their news feed on
facebook facebook also enables you the
advertiser to find the perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on facebook and targeted
audience so it's a platform that allows
you to put your product in front of
people based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about facebook is it's
lesser spend greater reach what do we
mean by that well traditionally facebook
is a little bit cheaper than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's gonna help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
other advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service or product but if they
didn't go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google
or some other advertising platform
facebook works the same way we want to
be able to reach out to people who
aren't fully committed at that point in
time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be
you know a brand that is trying to woo
my business okay so they know that
somebody that i'm associated with or
maybe i fit their demographic so they're
targeting my newsfeed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you haven't noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if i go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so i can't miss it if i'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see
simply learn has a example of a carousel
ad where they're showcasing their
different courses so this allows users
to view a range of all your different
products and services if you have
multiple products and services to offer
then the carousel ads would be a good
option for you so in addition to the
carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there in not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your carousel ad so facebook also
allows us to
advertise something called lead ads and
what lead ads allow us to do is obtain
user details okay so we can acquire or
get an email address or phone number
from somebody who's interested in our
product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the forum itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call to action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing
you know their different classes and
then they have the get started today
call to action to really punctuate the
slideshow ad so what's interesting is
you can really gauge a person's interest
by throwing different products or images
out there you know you can really
immerse a user's experience here by
showing different different images and
then the last type of ad on facebook is
called the collection ad and so these
ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you could see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential
more than seven billion dollars revenue
has been generated from instagram mobile
and it's home to more than two million
advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to instagram's
parent company facebook instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by facebook ads with
this you can advertise to people based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a url to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts
it'll help you plan ahead and automate
the process of publishing your posts
when your audience is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption hashtags videos goes live on
what day date or time
a consistent post schedule will enable
you to make the most out of instagram
it'll also keep your audience engaged
and also give you access to historical
posts if you want to repost your older
content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more
you also have a variety of ad formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they're using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted earthly tones
with a low key editing style
your content must feel down-to-earth and
your brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have acidically pleasing images and a
somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell
now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and by your
products
your captions can tell stories that can
help your brand appear more human and
build deeper connections with your
audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tells stories about
a different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues
that's the kind of stories you should
tell with your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your posts showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and
unprofessional find out what and how
many hashtags your competitors use and
how you can do something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way let's now go to number seven
take advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content and takes
advantages of their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads
most instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads corrosives are a combination
of images and videos and instagram
stories that enable you to combine
images and videos to create visually
attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
ralph lauren has to offer this
encourages his interested followers to
check out the page and buy something for
themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments you can
give away a product or a service which
enables you to boost engagement and
brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned brands need to be partnered with
contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important
you would need to track your contest
performance and promote the results on
other social media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to the savvy
marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews
another new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels instagram's answer to
tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
instagram engagement
[Music]
instagram how-to section
instagram is one of the fastest growing
social media networks its appealing
format and functionality have driven
people and businesses away from
traditional networks like facebook video
content is the most popular content type
on instagram so it's obvious that we
need to dedicate one lesson to how to
create optimize and promote your video
posts on instagram we will start this
lesson with showing you how to make
great instagram videos and talk about
the different types of videos for
instagram and we will then demo you how
to use the various video capturing and
editing tools you will find in the
instagram app we will close this lesson
with how businesses can use instagram
and how you can make money with it
instagram has extensive features to
create and promote videos
particularly with the growing appetite
in using instagram stories video is the
most important content form on instagram
it is important though to make sure that
before you start creating your video you
have a good idea of what you want to
achieve with it
is it to create awareness to generate
leads or are you answering questions
that clients may have
utilize the video editing features that
instagram has or use some external apps
if you want to go beyond what instagram
has to offer
there are enough tools for you to make
your instagram video a visual feast as
you can only create that on instagram
shooting and editing a great video
video is now the most shared content
type on instagram where in the early
days instagram video was only 15 seconds
long
nowadays you can upload 60 second videos
and turn multiple videos from your
camera roll into one video clip and
today instagram has lots of different
options within the app to create videos
and optimize them for the news feed or
for stories
recently instagram announced igtv
they're trying to take on youtube with a
dedicated video sharing app for vertical
and landscape videos with a maximum
length of 60 minutes for verified
accounts or accounts with a large
audience however anyone using the app
will be able to upload up to 10 minutes
of content to the platform
all in all instagram today is a
fantastic network for brands to build
brand awareness and to showcase their
products or services
to shoot great videos for instagram you
need to be aware of a few things
first of all you need to shoot the video
for instagram and instagram has its own
video formats video for the news feed
tend to be square whereas video for the
stories must be vertical
the aspect ratio for vertical videos is
9 by 16 which gives you a perfect 90
degrees flip for normal widescreen video
it's also better to use your phone's
native camera this will give you better
control over exposure and focus
instagram will allow you to upload
multiple clips and then edit them within
the instagram app
also think about short form versus long
form videos
stories are good for short clips whereas
igtv lends itself for longer videos
short videos are great for explaining
things that can be chopped up in steps
like recipes or how-to videos
long videos are good for brand
experiences and interviews
additionally it goes without saying you
always need to think about what you want
to achieve with your video what's your
end goal do you want new followers do
you want to get into engagement with
your followers
or do you want to drive traffic to your
website
all questions you need to think about
before you start shooting your video
video editing in external apps
once you have shot your video you can do
some basic editing within the instagram
app
you can also edit your video outside
instagram
the best environment for editing your
video is on your desktop computer
apps like adobe premiere from microsoft
or imovie from apple will give you an
extensive range of video and audio
editing options
you can then save the edited file and
move it to your phone via google drive
for instance after which you can import
the video file into instagram
there are also many video editing apps
for your mobile they won't give you as
many features as the desktop video
editing but they come a long way
one of my favorite apps is video show
what i like about video show is that it
has a wide range of templates you can
use as a format for your edited video
it also comes with an extensive song and
music library
video categories
so what type of video would work best on
instagram
instagram lends itself for what we call
snackable videos a snackable video is
short compelling and entertaining and
they are designed to drive the viewer to
some sort of action like driving them to
a landing page or to a fill-in form
here are some examples of topics for
your next instagram video
it can feature your product features to
show your followers what products you
carry and why those products are unique
you can show your product in action this
is great for breaking up the monotony of
staged product features
you can also give a sneak preview in
these type of videos you announce news
with a teaser which gives your followers
a sneak peek of what is to come
behind the scene videos work very well
on instagram they are great for building
a more personal relationship with your
audience think of office tours staff
introductions a day in the life of
tutorials will show your fans how to use
your product
and finally video series
they are great for building a community
and for engaging with them
once your community has seen an episode
and they like it they may want to come
back for more
video types
besides different topics for your videos
you can also think about different
formats for your videos
looping videos can be created within the
instagram app
looping videos start automatically from
the beginning after the clip finishes
they can be very creative and work well
to showcase movable product features
stop motion video is an animation that
is captured one frame at a time with
physical objects that are moved between
frames
when you playback the sequence of images
rapidly it creates the illusion of
movement
both ios and android have lots of apps
to create stop-motion video
in a time-lapse video you capture lots
of photos of a scene over a period of
time
these images are then put together to
create a seamless sped up video
time-lapse videos work very well to show
how something is built or made and
finally hyperlapse videos these are
videos that allow you to squeeze several
minutes of film into the one minute
maximum set by instagram
they are a bit like time lapse videos
but the camera is moving these videos
are great to show behind the scene
footage
how to use instagram video options
there are various ways that you can make
a video on instagram so let me show you
how to do that if you go to the
instagram app it takes you to the news
feed where you can browse
to make a quick video you just click on
the plus button and that takes you to
this shot of my phone for instance you
need to make sure you activate video
if you click on the button you can then
make your video
you click again to stop recording and
your video is ready
you can now play the video and if you
are happy with it you click next and
then you can add a filter if you want to
i will come back to filters and editing
later then you just click next write a
caption tag people add a location and
share it your video is now posted on
instagram
this is the simple way there's also a
more advanced way of making your video
so let me discard this video go back to
the news feed we're now in the news feed
the creative way to create a video is go
to your instagram stories
to access your instagram stories you can
swipe to the right or you can also click
on the little camera on the top left of
your screen that takes you to the same
video screen
and now you see that you have more
options you can see that here at the
bottom
you can do live video you can do normal
video
you can select boomerang video you can
do super zoom you can focus on your
video
rewind your video and record hands-free
so let me explain these in a bit more
detail
for normal video you just click on the
video button and then you can see that
it's recording and when you're ready
with the recording then you let go of
the button
and what you see now is that you have
some extra options at the top where you
can add effects stickers drawings or
text
so this is the simple way of making a
video with added effects
you can also go for live video and this
is just like facebook live when you
click on go live then instagram will
announce it to your followers and then
you can start your live broadcast
when you're ready with your live
broadcast instagram will ask you if you
want to post it on your stories or in
your news feed and then you're done with
your broadcast
a very creative way of making videos is
using boomerang
boomerang was a separate app which
became very popular it was then acquired
by instagram
a boomerang video is a video that
repeats itself
if i click on boomerang i'm going to get
the phone and i will turn it
then when you look at the video i
created you see how the video repeats
itself all the time
you can do a lot of creative things with
the boomerang effect you can make people
move back and forwards you can make
objects move up and down and then post
them as short repeating videos
you also see that you can change the
camera into selfie mode and you can add
some special overlay effects as well
so there's different filters i quickly
scan through those
when you're in selfie mode you can have
funny face alterations as well
so lots of different effects that you
can create here
so now let's look at the super zoom
video
the super zoom is a bit like paparazzi
also with different effects that you can
add to it so for instance i want hearts
on this video click on it and then it
will zoom in and you will see hearts
popping down
and here is the stamp effect click on it
and there you go
when i do a focus video it makes the
background blurred
with rewind video you can make the video
playback by itself
and then finally there's the hands-free
video
if you click on hands-free you don't
have to keep on pressing the record
button
so you have more freedom in camera
movement when you choose this option
so these are the different types of
video that you can make on instagram
how to use instagram video options and
filters
to show you how the effects work on
instagram i can go to instagram and then
into the story creation mode and here i
can just make a normal video
i can pan and move the video around a
bit
so the video is ready now and here i am
in the screen where i have the different
options to add creative effects to my
video so this is what i can do
first i can download a video on my phone
by clicking the downward arrow
i can then get different effects
i can add stickers i can play without
sound i can draw on the screen and i can
add text there are many different
options and when you click on the effect
button at the bottom you see the effects
that you can add to your video
there are effects that can be added when
there is a face on the screen but there
are also effects that can be added as an
overlay over the video
we can also add stickers like a location
sticker and a mention or a hashtag
sticker
interesting thing about these text type
stickers is that when you add these
instagram will actually understand the
text and will add them to the index for
search
you can easily move the stickers over
the screen you can add a time or a date
and you can also add quizzes so you can
ask a question for instance do you like
this
and then people can actually answer by
dragging the slider
you can do a poll and there's a whole
range of other stickers that you can add
to your video
you can draw as well you can have a thin
line or a thick line you can change the
color you can do special effects and you
can erase as well so you can do many
different effects with this you could
create an effect where you wipe out the
whole screen and then with the eraser
you can reveal sections of the video you
can get text and then when you're done
with it you can add a video to your
stories or save them as highlights on
your profile page or you can share it on
your news feed
monetizing your instagram videos
there are many different ways to make
money with instagram
you can make money as an influencer by
creating sponsored video posts
these are videos where you promote a
product from a brand
and the brand will reward you for giving
them access to your followers
tab influence is an excellent app to
connect brands with influencers you can
also sell your videos instagram is a
great place to showcase your content
2020 is an excellent website where you
can promote and sell your video content
and of course there is affiliate
marketing where you can promote your
products from your affiliate partners
and get a commission on each sale
sharesale is a website where you can
search for potential affiliate partners
or why not sell your instagram account
if you no longer want to manage it
famesweb is the place where you can do
this
finally instagram can also help you
indirectly to make money you could use
it to promote your youtube channel and
as we have learned in this course there
are many ways of making money through
youtube
takumi is one of the leading online
platforms where small influencers can
get connected with big global brands
when you have more than 1 000 followers
and you have good content you will be
able to use this network to identify
brands to work with
here are the takeaways of this lesson
video has become the top content type
shared on instagram
and today instagram has a whole range of
options to create and optimize your
videos for the news feed and for the
stories
short videos of maximum 60 seconds are
best for instagram
instagram uses looping videos they start
automatically from the beginning after
the clip finishes
use looping videos to showcase a fun or
versatile product feature
instagram has many different video
styles in the story's camera and once
you've shot your story video you have
plenty of options to customize them
takumi is an online platform where micro
influencers can connect with big global
brands to sell their original content
now let's get started first off let's
have a look at an introduction to
facebook
facebook was first launched in february
2004 and was initially known as the
facebook
in 2005 it removed d from its name and
has now become the facebook we all know
today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at instagram
it was launched in 2010 for ios and then
in 2012 for android by kevin systrom and
mike krieger
instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
platforms in the world
in april 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash and stock
now let's compare some stats between
facebook and instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats first off facebook
like i mentioned earlier facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world
reaching almost 60.6 of the internet it
has 2.5 billion monthly active users and
approximately 1.6 billion active users
in fact as of jan 2020 the us has
approximately 190 million and india has
approximately 280 million facebook users
an indication of a market that's still
ripe for the picking
now let's have a look at instagram
instagram although having released
significantly later earns its title of
the fastest growing social media
platform with 1 billion monthly active
users and 500 million daily users
in the united states there are
approximately 120 million and india has
close to 88 million instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic
age group of the user base
first off facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that facebook
isn't hip or isn't used all that much
anymore
this statistic has something different
to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take facebook first
in the united states users spend
approximately one hour on facebook every
day
in india users spend an average of three
hours a day on facebook
shockingly high numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the united states
users spend 23 minutes on average on
instagram in india users spend
approximately 45 minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that can work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media
e-commerce
automobile
and package goods
next time you're on facebook take a
closer look at your feed
there's a good chance you'll see most of
these industries post on it
next up instagram we have industries
like fashion
athleisure cosmetics automobiles and
food and beverages
i can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on instagram now
let's take a closer look at how facebook
can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to american
express 90 of users use customer service
as a deciding factor for whether or not
they continue to do business with an
organization
so customer service is pretty important
like i mentioned earlier your business
page provides a place where you can
offer your followers offers and other
advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community
a highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility of buying your
products and services
next we have facebook groups
with facebook groups you can build a
community of like individuals
some of the advantages that come with
this are
it provides a highly targeted audience i
mentioned earlier that business pages
provide you with a highly targeted
audience
groups take that to the next level it
enables everyone to learn from one
another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback your
customers who are also likely part of
the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with a community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next facebook has events
with facebook events your organization
will be able to mobilize your brand and
enable online consumer marketing
basically meaning that you have a
platform for letting people know about
important announcements not to mention
there's also the opportunity to get some
free advertising done events also help
you increase brand awareness
most people get to know about your brand
by attending the event or just seeing
the promotion for it now let's have a
look at facebook stories for groups and
pages a feature that is available for
both groups and pages it provides you
the ability to appropriately represent
your brand or business directly from
your mobile device or desktop
now some of its advantages
are that it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts
this way you can also vary the kind of
content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers stories help your brand show
that you're genuinely interested in your
audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency
next facebook has facebook messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly said to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction
and even if a customer doesn't give you
a transaction
at least you're increasing your brand
awareness
then we have facebook live
facebook live gives you a platform to
interact with your audience in real time
it can be used to diversify your content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially
live can also be used to show what
happens behind the scenes in your
organization
further helping humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the facebook shop
the facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store
it also has the following advantages
firstly you can use the shop to drive
new sales you can give the customers who
are on the fence about your product a
small push by engaging them and how can
you do that with deals and promotions
you can also reward advocates of your
brand with special benefits to be
availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition now let's have
a look at facebook ads
facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on facebook
now some of the advantages of facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money it also helps you re-advertise or
re-target your products to an existing
audience
and finally it helps increase revenue
sales and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about facebook ads you can check out our
facebook ads video i'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature facebook offers to help you with
marketing
facebook insights i'm sure all of you
have heard about google analytics
let's just say this is facebook's
version of that with insights you get
information that can help you refine
your brand strategy by tracking and
measuring results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement
actions people who are viewing your
posts when your fans are online the type
of posts that are working for you and
much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
facebook helps you with marketing
now let's move on to instagram first off
we have instagram business accounts
instagram business accounts enable
brands to be recognized as businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer
it's only with a business account that
you can get instagram insights we'll
talk about insights in a little more
detail in a little bit
you can also add a contact button on
your profile
enabling users to connect with you
directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer
by adding what industry you belong to in
your bio and finally you also have the
ability to add links to your instagram
stories now i'm sure you've all seen the
see more option in your stories so now
you know how that shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name i'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about instagram stories
with instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement
build brand awareness and to drive sales
you can also use stories to provide
recent updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos next up let's talk
about instagram dms or direct messages
dms help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers
their loyalty towards your brand is
improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry
and as an extension of the last few
points this leads to easier lead
generation and increased sales
next up we have igtv
now ittv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improved engagement and greater chances
of conversions
finally it also helps build a community
of a highly targeted audience
next we have instagram live
instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time
further improving your discoverability
and strengthening your connection with
the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have instagram ads
instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements
you decide how they appear and who sees
them like facebook instagram has a
number of different ad types to offer
they are photo ads video ads carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up instagram offers an instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability
and since it provides visual marketing
it also leads to more sales
and finally instagram insights
instagram's answer to facebook insights
and google analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
impressions and reach
best and worst performing content
profile visits website clicks and much
more
and there you go that's every way
facebook and instagram can help you with
marketing
now we've laid out the facts for you
keep in mind your requirements and make
a wise choice so let's talk about how to
create a youtube ad so this is going to
require
some access to google ads and we'll go
over that in a few minutes here but
first we need to think about setting up
a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign so we get eyeballs you know we
want to pay cost per 1000 impressions or
we want to run some actionable type ads
to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video out
here that is going to show on youtube
and to our target audience so
or whether it be a bumper ad that's only
gonna be six seconds long we need to be
able to figure out what type of ad we
want to run so here i am in google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
youtube
we need to make sure that
we're choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video
basically what we're doing is we're
going to tell google we want to go ahead
and set up some video ads on youtube and
so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable cpm model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to
you know move forward with selecting our
ad so you can see here after i set up my
campaign now i'm just going to go
through some of the settings for my ad
and i'm going to give it a campaign name
a budget okay when it starts or ends the
bidding strategy so again we're going to
focus on cost per 1000 impressions and
then here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with youtube videos so
we also have the option to select video
partners on the display network so that
means that
if you want your video to show on
websites that want to host ads in video
format then you can select this option
here notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on youtube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so i'm gonna
stick with the video partners okay
youtube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create an a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting our audience so here we
got demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas our browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
youtube videos or we can go with youtube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to bumper
ads so we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but i just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to where
you want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so it's really crucial here
that you go through these steps and
these options very closely so because
you want your video to show in front of
the right audience on the right
placement so let's talk about how you
can optimize your youtube ads so once
you get your campaign set up once you
select your channel or the type of
videos where you want your ad to be and
you select your target audience and
you're off and running with your video
ad well we're going to give you some
tips here that you can focus on for
optimizing those ads and so going back
to what i was just saying on the setup
you want to carefully define your
metrics and goals okay so that's step
one so when you're setting up the
campaign remember you have that option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign that can be brand awareness it
could be a sale it could be a lead so to
me that's the you know a very critical
step one so you want to make sure you
align your goal with your video and then
the second is track low performing ad
placements so if we just ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and choose the ad placements and
remove them okay so let me show you an
example of what that means so if i'm
back in google i'm going to go to my
campaign and i'm going to select
placements and here i can see placements
but then i'm going to select where my
ads show and so this is important you
want to be able to scan the list of
placements where the ad was shown so if
you don't like one of the placements on
youtube you can always select it edit it
and exclude it from the campaign or
record so that's really the key is you
want to be able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing at placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta so
again depending on the ad type you know
if it's a true view ad 20 seconds long
you want to have a call to action you
want to maybe even have your domain name
at the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be as an other
setting you can use closed captioning in
your ads to make it more interactive so
that way people can actually see or read
what the ad is all about just to make it
a bit more interactive okay you can
always perform a b testing on your ads
so if you have one ad version you can
create another one just to see what it
which one performs better testing is
always a positive okay so if you're
paying too much maybe think about
reducing your bids so if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids at the ad group
level so reduce bids in areas where you
see lower performance so in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that
really you want to make sure that your
ad is you know is with the end viewer
you don't want to put out an ad that
isn't going to give somebody you know a
good feeling after they've watched it
okay so you want to make sure viewers
find the content relevant so if they
don't find it relevant then that means
your engagement rate and your engagement
is probably going to be low so you want
to take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any ad you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise you know people are
going to be turned off or not engaged
and just going to go ahead and skip it
anyway so you want to make sure you get
the purpose of it right up front and out
of the way okay you can also include
visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads
and you want to be able to you know
measure the ad performance based on the
metrics we discussed i mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when i say good quality i mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting if so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a b testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some asian
markets european markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders uh from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so their global
brand they really wanted to take a
different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so
what they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they wanted once take advantage
of all the different ad types that
youtube had to offer and let's take a
look at one of those ads here so if we
go to youtube
and let's just take a look at this one
minute ad here 53 second ad by super dry
i'm ready now super jam paigey cakey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting
the jacket you're pulling the jacket
your play pal and posing
you'll take five in this jacket you all
wanna find this jacket i washed the
jacket it's ruined
it shall dust that mate
take away free and plate
catch your breath not your death in this
jacket it's the jacket you're preening
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see that
you know it was it had some particular
goals there and so super dry is pretty
well known so it probably wasn't built
around brand awareness per se it was
probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video it was
definitely not a bumper ad because
bumper ads are six seconds so it was
definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds that a long
time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender
some younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million but the more
important thing is because these videos
were to drive action and so they were
able to see a four to one ratio on
return on investment and as a result
these jackets saw a hundred and thirty
eight percent increase in brand lip i
mean the jacket ad so it was a pretty
successful campaign see as well
choreographed good audio good video just
well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers under their belt because
of this ad alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and target them with a cool video and
given that youtube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
there's trueview in-stream ads uh with a
cost per view uh through a skippable
video ad format and they they also use
the shoppable ad format so that is
another option on youtube so they took
advantage of all youtube had to offer in
terms of who they were trying to target
the length of the ad
and
given that their product or selling a
product or promoting a product they will
take advantage of the trueview shoppable
ad format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again
based on the numbers that they're
reporting and so
basically that's the power of youtube
getting out in front of your audience
with a really good video ad targeting an
audience taking advantage of different
formats today we're going to talk about
how to increase instagram followers
today's webinar we're going to have some
tips and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user base growth of more than 300
year over year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's
100 million photos plus uploaded daily
and then there are 400 million stories
posted daily so when you post something
you can create a story out of it and
there's 400 million of those per day and
then there's more than 50 billion photos
shared to date so since 2010 platform
nat which is now owned by facebook has
become really really popular a good
place for you if you have your own
company if you have your own brand if
you have your own product it's a good
place for you to really showcase that
service that product that brand because
of the user base how easy it is to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story so mention
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through instagram mobile so on
top of everything i just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers up
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
instagram which is owned by facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on instagram so instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
gonna go through some tips and tricks
today and we're gonna talk about
everything there is to know about
instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if i go to my instagram account for
example using my desktop i could see my
profile and i can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are gonna
look at and they're gonna decide whether
to follow you or not based on primarily
that bio that's where it all starts so
make sure you have a good bio that's tip
number one so you'll have to make sure
that your landing page is also mobile
optimized since most instagram users are
on mobile so if you're going to put a
link to your website and somebody's on
the instagram app and they see your bio
and they like it and you have a link to
your website make sure that lanny page
they go to is mobile optimized so tip
number two everything you do on
instagram when it comes to posting
evolves around hashtags so that's the
backbone of the platform just like most
platforms out there social media
platforms like twitter or facebook
pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so instagram is no
different but in this case you really
really want to take advantage of the
hashtag so hashtags are there to help
users find your content so you want to
start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't mean really
mean somebody's going to be interested
in what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
day to post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 p.m on thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time a day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here to steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitor's brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted engage with them okay it doesn't
take that much time it's a good way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see what they've
posted in terms of videos and images and
i can like or comment so just doing
something as simple as this
gets you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you can find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your credibility because
you're connecting with somebody who has
a large audience as well so do a little
bit of homework find people out there in
your industry who has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they got to have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location
is likely to engage with you so tip
seven use instagram stories to attract
followers and grow your user base a
story's a really big feature on
instagram so what stories could be used
for is just show footage of an
environment so it could be your office
it could be your home it could be you
know the playground it could be the golf
course it could be anywhere that you
want to show vintage of so you want to
post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog posts you
can post positive user reviews so these
are all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlight serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your contents
about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote and promote your
product highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential followers so it teases what
the contents about it creates a trailer
so to speak for your brand and promote
your product so use highlights and again
any users out there who have good
examples of highlights go ahead and put
those in the content section or comment
section uh right below this video so
remember stories have only a 24-hour
lifespan so highlights can be used to
give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the contents about it promotes the
product and it really kind of
accentuates that story tip number nine
ask for followers so sometimes people
need a little push before they can
follow you on instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers in the caption
the comment section or even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know i got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post you know
really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engagers then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if if it
is popular then go ahead and say hey
this is a popular post you know think
about following me or put something in
the comment section you want to do it
kind of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just work it in to some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence and asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on youtube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
youtube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and say hey you like this you know go
ahead and follow us it's that simple so
tip number 10 take on the latest trends
to get more followers so align your
content to cater to trendy topics or
hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here's your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keeping in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
can just do something for fun especially
if you have a lot of followers if you
have a lot of followers then somebody's
going to take part in it so don't be
afraid to run contests just to make it
fun and light it up a little bit so each
tag can bring you a new audience member
who could be a potential follower so
anytime you run a contest people are
gonna tag their friends to let them know
about that contest so those friends are
going to come over and likely engage so
that's the beauty of running a contest
or giveaway is chances are word's going
to spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with post so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of instagram content
so that mean what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water suppose so to speak and you're
probably gonna get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the genes industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and and that kind of blurs your
your personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are going to start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like socialblade that could tell you how
many followers you've lost over time and
how engaged they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so let's take a look at
socialblade as an example here so if i
go over here i'm gonna go to socialblade
here i can enter in basically any
account after a register and i could see
how that account has performed you know
where they rank you know how many
uploads they have what country they
focused on what industry and the beauty
here is i could see and i'm looking at
youtube as an example i could see you
know how my post to perform well you
could do this for instagram you could do
it for facebook so you can really get an
idea of
how your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're gonna do is you're gonna go
to your app right and then from the app
you can basically look at your insights
from there so in the app itself you're
gonna click on the upper right three
lines and from there you're gonna see
insights and when you go to insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions and some
engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns and post what posts
receive the most amount of engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use instagram ads so instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mention this on other webinars for
facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i can see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel to really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's gonna tell
you you know what your audience size is
your potential reach okay what your
daily results would be so you're gonna
get all that information when you run
your ads on facebook ads manager but
it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting units you need
meaning you know who saw the ad did they
click on it okay you can refine that
target audience you can go back into
facebook ads manager and refine who your
audience is so lots of flexibility here
and advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people are
wearing were involved in this you could
see lots of different examples here some
cute ones you know some funny ones some
humorous ones so you know just taking a
look at something like pizza which you
know most people enjoy you know most and
you can kind of appreciate you know how
much of an advantage instagram can be
because it really you can accentuate
photos you can have fun with it you can
really run some contests here you know
give us your best pizza photo so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to measuring the
engagement of your instagram post you're
definitely going to need a social media
tool so you're also going to need it if
you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if i go to later here i can
see you know i can use this to upload
my images to my profile so here you can
see it's scheduled throughout the day of
the week so that way we're not
overlapping you know we're scheduling
based on the times of the day that
people are going to look at this so
you know here i could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature styles to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all this
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example
of what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comments section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user-generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so if you do that you're likely
to build that relationship and you know
increase your followers and you want to
be able to see of that user generated
content that ugc which is performing
which is not performing okay so
basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working so take advantage of
that remember going back to hashtags you
could set up your own unique hashtag and
ask your users to post images or videos
relating to that which you can post in
your brand's account so just like the
whole pizza thing they're saying hey
look you know use daily pizza for a
feature okay that's a good example of
something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on youtube
just like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're gonna create a video you know go
ahead and you know you can make it short
make it fun okay you can see here these
guys are just showing you how pizza's
made doesn't take a long time they're
just going through the motions they're
not boring you with details they're not
talking really quick and easy just to
give you an idea it doesn't have to be
as serious it can be fun so video
content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely gonna
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest
or or youtube the whole idea is to get
users to your instagram page and
encourage them to follow it so you know
you can always put that url in you know
other platforms like youtube nothing
wrong with that at all okay you can also
promote your page offline with print ads
and during other relevant events and
then i would even take this to further
is you probably see you know
an instagram
logo on a web page along with other
social media icons so you always want to
help promote instagram on your web page
as well but you can do it for offline
with print ads so you can simply just
put you know whatever your your slug is
for instagram whatever your id is
whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online today
we're going to talk about how to
increase twitter followers so welcome
and let's get started so with twitter
it's all about tweets it's actually a
verb now uh when you do something on
twitter you actually tweet and there are
a lot of people out there tweeting in
fact twitter has over 1.3 billion
accounts so
a lot of tweets going on in the world of
twitter so as of the third quarter in
2018 last year twitter had 326 million
global monthly active users okay so
active meaning every day using the
platform on a daily basis so a lot of
people using twitter it's very easy to
use as you'll find out and what you're
going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our youtube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding facebook or
instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on youtube or if it's not unpublished on
youtube use it with twitter you're going
to get more engagement so twitter has 75
of its users use the platform for news
okay so people go to twitter to get
their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
percent of b2b businesses market on
twitter so not only is it a b2c or
business to consumer platform it's a b2b
business to business platform so a lot
of businesses are on twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a keyword friendly bio okay
a link to your website and a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if i go to twitter here we go to
simply learn twitter account okay their
handle is simply at simplylearn okay and
they've customized the header they use
their logo now if you're an individual
you probably want to use a nice profile
pic here where they're based a little
bit about them so
just a you know customized complete
profile goes a long way you don't have
to go overboard with an elaborate design
so to speak but just make it stand out
make it associate with who you are as a
person and a brand those are best
practices in getting that profile up and
running you don't want to use something
bland and generic you know take the
extra step create something unique make
sure your profile is unique you have a
good image okay make sure it's complete
with you know telling people who you are
and what you're all about that's really
the first step on really any social
media platform so
you want to promote your twitter profile
to drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on facebook
if you're already on instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like i said if
you're on facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys i'm on twitter you
know come follow me so you could also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials events to put that
twitter profile on okay so it doesn't
have to be within the social media
sphere it could be even on your website
it can be even in email so you can
basically promote that profile again you
want to make that profile that handle
easy to remember so totally real person
is the profile on this example we're
going to use that profile every way we
can whether that be offline or online
you don't don't be afraid to use it on a
business card especially if it's easy i
can just simply go to twitter and type
in that handle so you want to stay
active on twitter with regular retweets
replies and favorites and that's just
it's just so easy to retweet and reply
and add favorites so let's take a look
at that on twitter so you could just
simply i'm logged in as me and if i want
to retweet something that simply learn
did i can just simply click on the
retweet button and i can add a comment
if i want to and then i'm going to
retweet it's that simple so now that
tweet is going to show up on my profile
my handle and i could simply like it if
i scroll down here okay top 10 it trends
shaping 2019 notice a simple tweet
supported with an image so i'm just
going to like that so i can even comment
on it i can click on the comment and
click a reply here okay and that's going
to show up in this tweet here just like
if i click on this i'll be able to see
what other people have written and so
it's that simple if i want i can just
click on the email button and even send
a message to somebody right from that
tweet the point is i can do everything i
need to do right in the platform but to
get started if you don't have any tweets
you know go and find other companies
similar to you look at their tweeting
and you can always retweet that that's a
good way to get going with tweets that's
what i started doing when i started on
twitter in 2008 i didn't know what to
write particularly and i didn't know how
to write it particularly well so i
looked at what other people wrote and
and tweeted and just retweeted those
that's a good way to get your twitter
account started okay so engaging with
users is a great way to get more
followers so on simplylearn i retweeted
one of their tweets i liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably gonna
get their attention somebody at
simplylearn is gonna say okay rob
sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within twitter or as i'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like sprout social or
hootsuite or later or buffer and there's
plenty of social media platforms out
there for you to schedule tweets point
is you want to be able to schedule those
tweets when it's the appropriate time so
you don't want to do it in the middle of
the evening because what's going to
happen is
likely by the morning other tweets are
going to bury your tweet so you want to
be able to find the appropriate time to
post your tweets so according to a
survey conducted by hubspot the best
time to post is between 12 and 3 p.m and
why is that well most people are usually
on lunch checking their phones yes
twitter has an app and in fact most
people use the app just like on
instagram just like on youtube the app
is very popular on twitter so it's very
easy for somebody to check tweets
especially during the lunch hour and
then from five to six pm that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to
check the twitter and react during those
times okay so that was a survey
conducted by hubspot but really what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
one of these social media platforms like
a hootsuite or later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when a what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're going to
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if i go back to twitter you
know twitter's always going to recommend
somebody for me to follow and normally
those are people that are similar as
myself okay so they're not just going to
choose random people they're going to
choose people who are following people
you're following so there's going to be
a connection to some degree or they
could be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so
you want to go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
twitter is if you follow somebody on
twitter chances are they're going to
follow you back you know i was once told
when i was using twitter that hey you
want to give somebody about three days
to follow you back so that's always what
the rule i stuck to you know wait about
three days start following people you
can see here 833 people that or accounts
twitter accounts that simply learns
following and over 10
900 followers to simply learn's twitter
account so for me i don't mind having a
nice balance myself i have just as many
followers as i do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if i
click on find people i know then i can
upload my contacts from outlook or gmail
and they're going to find people who are
already on twitter based on who i'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way i'm going to follow
simply learn because i wasn't following
them prior so now i just clicked on the
follow button now i am following so now
i'm going to see simply learns tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweets so
what we did was we scoured twitter from
2018 and we went ahead and picked out
some tweets that we thought were pretty
good and so the first one is wendy's now
i don't know if any of you have actually
eaten at wendy's i used to eat at
wendy's a while ago i know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they incorporated that frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is last january they're encouraging
people to use their app and they're
using that frosty as kind of a carrot if
you will okay it's a catch it's a
giveaway so they were able to you know
basically wrap a bunch of things into
one so get encourage people to take part
and i'm sure a lot of people went ahead
and took part of this but we could
definitely see that 206 retweeted this
tweet 302 basically commented on it and
over 3 000 liked the tweet so the tweet
was good and it basically engaged with
users who doesn't like a free giveaway
especially free frosty so that's why
this particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience their
audience they're they're giving
something away to their audience just by
allowing them to you know use their app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and i like it apparently a lot more
people than i did three thousand plus
also like this tweet and so moving on to
how to increase your followers on
twitter you want to mention other people
in your tweets to increase engagement so
what do we mean by that so let's look at
twitter so go back if we look at simply
learn just take a look at some of their
tweets what they're doing if we scroll
down here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hashtags but you can
also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
you the pound sign but if we scroll down
here if you use the at symbol you're
actually mentioning somebody so in this
case we're mentioning matt bailey so
matt bailey says is matt bailey's handle
and so if you get a shout out to
somebody they're gonna pick up on that
and then they're going to probably
follow you okay who doesn't appreciate
getting recognized for something
especially something as small as a tweet
okay notice i can go ahead and click
follow if i want to follow them out
bailey but it's not a bad idea to add
people into your tweet and you simply do
that by just using the ad symbol and
using their twitter handle it's a good
way to get recognized by that twitter
follower it also increases engagement
because it's adding validity to the
tweet and it definitely catches the
attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
gonna do is start some type of twitter
relationship okay they're gonna then
follow you you're gonna follow them and
chances of them retweeting you in the
future or mentioning you in the future
is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is find and use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is mandatory on
twitter you need to use hashtags
twitter's all about hashtags every tweet
that goes out should have a hashtag okay
so what you can do is figure out what
hashtags are trending so here what
twitter does is they trends for you so
these are all specific hashtags that are
trending it's mother's day happy mother
hey sunday morning whatever works for
you these are trends that happen to be
moving meaning a lot of people are using
them clicking on them okay so you can
use a popular hashtag what i would also
recommend is using a unique hashtag the
rule of dumb is usually about two
hashtags in a tweet but that's a rule of
thumb but rules are made to be broken do
what's best for you if you want to
include more than two hashtags go for it
the only thing i'm recommending is
include a hashtag so find out which
trending you could just look right in
twitter or you could just create your
own unique hashtag it works both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go to that particular
handle that hashtag and so when they
look at the hashtag gonna see all the
tweets with that hashtag in it so that's
the idea behind hashtags you want to
have hashtags okay so if somebody clicks
on a hashtag that you used then they're
likely going to see your tweet in that
hashtags feed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your branded audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through twitter
search thus improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit twitter has
search functionality so somebody can
simply go in and start searching on
twitter so if i go back to twitter i can
just do a hashtag and start typing in
something like spanish and i'm gonna get
some of the most popular spanish
hashtags or hashtags with the word
spanish in it and so this is an idea for
me that if i want to use a hashtag with
spanish in it these are some ideas but
they're certainly searchable on twitter
so if i just click on spanish okay i'm
gonna be able to see all the hashtags
with the word spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of twitter bar none
so some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know i work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if i wanted to be just like
simply learn well i could simply just go
to their twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtags so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so i can simply just
click on the 10
900 followers that they have and what i
could do is i can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's a good tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when i say mimic i mean
what i'm saying is pull best practices
from that twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow bill gates or elon musk
or richard branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer has an influence
on a lot of people okay but make sure
they're in your industry that's the key
if you can make sure they're in your
industry and you follow them chances are
if they look at your twitter account and
see you're posting or maybe retweeting
some of their tweets they're likely to
follow you and if they're following you
your tweets are gonna show up on their
handle on their feed and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so again this
will help you gain followers since you
can replicate what they've done with
their profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mind so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their post so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simply learn so
if i click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that matt bailey was at so it was a
retweet from matt bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learn's doing is they're including
either a video or they're including an
image in every tweet and so that's
likely to boost up engagement so
according to buffer which is a another
social media platform adding a relevant
high quality image in your tweets can
help you gain more than a hundred and
fifty percent engagement okay videos are
six times more likely to be retweeted so
if you have an arsenal video or even one
video don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
snowball effect just by using images
okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars i
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets to get
some to some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your tweet so you can use
twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
i go here i could see this person is
promoting their handle but if i go down
here i can see a promoted tweet by
constant contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some media budget to go
ahead and either promote your tweet or
advertise on twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from constant contact
so if i click on that i'm gonna go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the right audience
and so twitter's no exception so with
twitter you could put yourself in front
of the right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tell your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or trend or account to be
in front of it's targeting is based on
either engagement or it's based on
keywords i.e
so really you could tailor who you want
your tweet or your handle to be in front
of and so that's the really the benefit
of twitter if you have a lot of active
users on twitter you can really put
yourself in front of those active users
if they're your relevant audience at a
low cost per click so it's definitely
worth the test so you want to offer
twitter support to your users okay so i
can't stress this enough okay so what
you want to do is when users have
questions about your product they're
more likely to tweet you for support
hence they're likely to follow your
account so don't be afraid to use the
messaging option as well so we go back
to twitter okay chances are somebody
might have a question for you here you
can look at big ads it's great
connecting with ppc experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of twitter
followers you want to build your twitter
following naturally twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shut down shut down by
twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices and organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories i mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things i do is i'm definitely one
for industry news so if i'm in the
industry of digital marketing if google
did a recent algorithm update i'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it i
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if i blog i'm going to make sure
that blog gets over to twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so i'm in digital
marketing i deal with pay-per-click seo
but am i going to just do pay-per-click
and seo no i know that analytics i know
that you know google tag manager i know
that a b testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so i'm
going to branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing a variety to the type of
content you share so don't just stick to
one thing you know feel free to reach
out a little bit shake things up by
sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so
here you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that insight with you
and so this was interesting when i saw
this so what i did was i simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you want to look at this particular
study i just went to twitter and i typed
in that hashtag and now i'm going to be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 i teach friends shaping 2019
so i'm just following the twitter handle
that they used so forrester does a lot
of good research a lot of good insights
and so what they've done here that makes
this tweet look so good is they've
actually put an image of the results in
the tweet so they used an image to help
gain engagement or increase engagement
notice they also gave a shout out to
somebody as well as use some good
hashtagging so good tweet this was back
in 2016 but again a good use of the
image with the tweet so you want to
organize tweet chats to interact with
your users and bring in new followers so
you know you basically want to be
organized when you're dealing with with
chat so tweet chats enable you send out
tweets on a particular topic using a
designated hashtag so during a certain
time to interact with your your
followers and other users so you could
do it at a specific time to really get
out a specific topic but you want to be
able to stay organized so that you know
you what you're chatting about is
reaching the right audience and you're
getting the right following and the
right engagement okay you can also pin
your best updates and tweets to your
profile so you can just use that pin and
what that's going to do is pin it to the
top and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engage with and that's
going to encourage them to share and
probably follow you so and and that's
always what you want to do you always
want to put your best foot forward so
pin your best tweet to your profile so i
mentioned this earlier use tools to
schedule when to publish your tweets so
here are some of the most popular
platforms you know i use sprout social
so if we take a look at sprout social
here i'm in sprout social i'm connected
to my twitter account i can simply just
start tweeting about something here so
you can see it's going to let me know
how many characters i have remaining so
to 180 to start out with when i'm done
tweeting notice i can add an emoji i can
upload media
i can tag a specific location okay i can
even you know call out a specific
twitter profile now i can schedule this
myself or i can use the schedule below i
can pick and choose a time to schedule
the tweet now again you want to be able
to use the sprout social whatever social
media tool you're using two figure out
when the best time of day and the day of
the week to actually tweet when are you
getting the best engagement so ideally
that's what you want to do you want to
tweet when you're likely to get the best
engagement when those eyeballs are
actually going to look at that tweet
okay but you also want to separate out
your tweets so they're not on one on top
of another because if you actually tweet
back to back then those tweets are just
gonna get buried so if you spread them
out a little bit then you're likely to
maximize your number of impressions or
eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you in not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social hootsuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaged
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine-tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember wendy's
gave away that free frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means
more engagement more eyeballs which
could lead to basically future customers
so contests can help increase your reach
and exposure and each new participant
can be considered as a potential
follower so it also gives your followers
an opportunity to tag their friends who
would be interested in participating so
really come up this is a great way to be
creative come up with a good idea to get
your your audience involved because
what's likely going to happen is your
audience is going to share this contest
with others that aren't following you
and so what's going to happen is when
they share it you're going to get more
followers you're going to get more
eyeballs and again potentially more
customers so embed your twitter updates
on your website you could simply do that
uh it's very simple but when you do then
people to your website will be able to
see your tweets so if i just go to my
website here if i scroll down we
actually have your twitter embedded on
our website as well because we want you
know people to see what we're tweeting
about and you can see i just retweeted
the simply learn tweet at the beginning
of this particular webinar and it's
showing up in my feed here so that's
when people actually go to my website
they'll be able to see what i retweeted
and that's going to help simply learn
out because simply learn is likely to
get some clicks on this particular tweet
from my website so it's also a good way
to keep your website fresh and updated
because if you're an active twitter user
and you're tweeting a lot then hey
that's going to show up on your website
and it's going to show that hey you're
fresh you're engaging you keep up to
date it's just going to make it look
good and make your website feel fresh
and not stale so embedding your twitter
updates will help you add new followers
as well because it's people who are
coming to your website that may not even
know you have a twitter account so you
can also do this in a blog post and a
newsletter and other forms of
communication media so it doesn't
necessarily have to be just your website
but i would definitely recommend it
because it will give a boost to your
twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention when this is from playstation
so playstation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on apple tv today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
apple tv so you never know what's going
to happen with a tweet when you tweet
good things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your twitter followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
storytelling when it comes to consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the storytelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of improvement
in the last several years in social
media with more and more brands moving
towards this idea of sort of humanizing
their companies by telling the stories
that come out of the company itself out
of the use of the product or even out of
the consumer stories that you know share
how products benefit their lives or
again just what goes on in that
interaction and that dynamic between the
organization and between the customer
side of things now when it comes to
storytelling there's several different
ways in which this approach offers value
to a business and one of the key ones is
on the emotional side we've talked a lot
in the social sharing dynamic in some of
the other areas of you know the the
spread and the viral concept about how
emotion is one of the most powerful
things that impact people's decision
making and engagement with the brand so
when it comes to creating that emotional
connection or leaving people with some
type of emotional response storytelling
is one of the most powerful ways to
impact that it gives you an opportunity
to sway the emotion of consumers in
terms of how they look at or view or are
receptive to your brand
now another thing that storytelling can
really do that adds a lot of value is
the idea of making you credible because
a lot of times the way we tell stories
especially when we're incorporating in
true to life examples or you know
consumer stories there's an implied
credibility that comes through that
storytelling and comes through those
third-party experiences that can help
people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling brings a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories
we are much more capable of recalling
broad ideas and concepts and emotions
when they're communicated via a story so
if we give someone a list of facts a
list of selling points you know a list
of reasons why to do business with you
the ones that touch them emotionally or
that you know problem solve those tend
to stick with them but a lot of the data
gets lost but when we put it in the
format of a story and someone is sharing
what their experience was our brains
literally archive it and categorize it
differently and our recall level goes up
so again along with building trust and
along with creating that that emotional
impact the fact that people are better
able to recall the information that's
communicated to them via that story
helps make it a very powerful marketing
tool now in addition to that it's
important to keep in mind that on
average people tend to be daydreamers in
fact study after study shows that if our
minds aren't occupied with an important
task if we're not truly focused on
something we tend to drift off and when
we look at that concept of daydreaming
the average human spends literally half
of their waking hours daydreaming we
average 2 000 waking drifts per day with
an average length of about 14 seconds so
you do the math on that 2000 times times
14 seconds that's a pretty good portion
of our day where our brain is drifting
off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drips we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging story we are better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you
now think of storytelling from sort of
the mindset of how we meet and engage
with other people so in general when
we're meeting up with a prospective
friend or a job prospect maybe we're
coming for an interview a service
workers even just a stranger on the
street any conversation that goes past
just hello how are you doing and the
cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information about who another
person is
and in those interpersonal relationships
the types of questions we ask you know
the words we use they're indicative of
the type of relationship we want to
build so clearly if you know if you're
single and you see someone else that you
know you hope might be single that might
be one of the early questions you ask
and then based on whether you know
there's a romantic interest there you're
probably going to ask different
questions than if it's a interview
prospect for a job or if you're meeting
up with a you know co-worker for the
first time the relationship that we're
looking for denotes the type of
information we want and that's one of
the important things for us to keep in
mind when it comes to storytelling is we
also have the ability to tailor our
story to the audience so we can put
those different features up front we can
weave them in in a different way if
we're appealing to a group of 60
something females that love to sew
versus a group of 20 something
millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
features there's also different things
that we're going to put forward if we're
proposing you know million dollar
contract versus a 25 impulse buy that
someone can you know click and order
online and have delivered the next day
now on the business side of this we need
to think about what the story that we
need is because a lot of times we get so
focused in business on getting the
conversion
that we forget that sometimes part of
getting that conversion is creating
those emotions building that credibility
and trust you know helping them have
exposure to what's possible and for a
long time this has been done through
education we might put up videos or
articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind
so a quote that i really love about this
concept that sort of lays the foundation
of why it's so important comes from the
chief content officer over at digitas
and he says the challenge is clear by
now intrusive interruptive self-centered
marketing no longer works the way it
once did and its effectiveness will only
continue to diminish in the social age
because again the way that we share
information back and forth with each
other and the ways that messages spread
it happens differently in the social
media age than it did before when it was
more advertising focused and where
marketing really was more about you know
pushing the advertise pushing the
message and sort of the don draper style
of you know if you don't like the
conversation change the conversation and
tell people what you want them to hear
because so much marketing is now driven
by consumers through that conversation
we need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone in spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that i want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach
and i love this seth godin quote that
really pairs up with that idea the best
part of show-and-tell has never been the
telling part it's been the showing
letting someone see an experience and
inviting them into that shared
experience and that's one of those
things that makes the social version of
storytelling really more like story
sharing especially if you want to do it
in a way that creates that back and
forth consumer engagement story telling
in its traditional sense is more the
stories that we've put into commercials
and advertising and there's a place for
that there's a place to put that
together in the social realm and it's
very important but the other area that
that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people
now there's tons of questions you could
ask yourself to start building your
story
but we can focus in on a couple key
areas as a starting point to build from
one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a founder's
story now for a lot of brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was steve jobs and the role
he played at apple or walt disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire disney complex
or loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now great
example of this is spanx the founder
sarah blakely has really embraced the
story both of how she came up with the
idea which was basically she was trying
to fit into a pair of cream pants for a
party and they didn't fit quite right
and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to neiman marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room
and she went in and she put on a pair of
white pants and came out and said you
know here's what i look like without
them and went back in and put her pair
of spanx on under the white pants and
came back out and said now here's what
happens when i'm wearing these and the
buyer from neiman marcus ended up
placing a huge order and it was the
first major sale that she got that put
her in place somewhere
so those stories and sort of the yeah
this is how it happened you know this is
literally what a difference it makes
that becomes part of the brand and sort
of sarah blakely's journey as an
entrepreneur and you know moving her way
up into the you know the forbes list
of uh you know highest earning females
in the united states
all of that plays a huge role in how
they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain wendy's in
the us and canada where dave thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know he passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that a working-class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working-class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was ceo to see him
show up in a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays into the narrative of wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there
post cereal paired up with burns group
and use real factory workers to create a
round of honey bunches of oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
i get out of work and and i go to the
store
and somebody's
smelling around
i smell cookies i said oh no you just
smell me i just got out of work that's
honey bunches old that's all i said
don't eat me now
now they're short
simple easy stories there's nothing
complex to them they more just make you
smile and laugh but they're the types of
stories that come from listening to the
people who work at your company from
thinking about how your company and
their experience impacts the world
around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great or the reason you
think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or
on the b2b side of things you know that
the buying agent is looking at that
they're trying to fix
now a great example of this is airbnb or
you could look at uber or lyft on a
similar vein
allowing people to experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money you know from something that
might have been sitting there empty
anyways you know that idea that when
you're traveling you don't have to stay
in a bland expensive hotel in fact when
i travel for business pretty much any
place i go i always book via airbnb
because
you know if i can have a bedroom and a
living room and a kitchen especially for
traveling as a family and there can be
you know separate bedrooms as opposed to
having my kids all stay in the same room
with my husband and i
it just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes
and even on the side of trying to
recruit people to put their properties
it becomes about the freedom and the
lifestyle that's enabled and there's
tons of examples on youtube of people
sharing how you know leasing out that
you know their vacation property the
rest of the year when they're not there
you know pays for the vacation property
and more or you know the people who now
travel full-time because they're able to
lease out you know their apartment or
their home or something else on airbnb
the story side comes from the problems
that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is dollar shave club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and
you know it shows up right at your house
and you don't ever have to think about
it anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example
as a founder of my own club i'd love to
know how does yours work dollar shave
club presents what the fact it's simple
you choose from one of our three great
razors we'll give you a free reusable
handle and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks that means you get to shave with
the fresh blood any time you want which
feels amazing
why be locked into a contract
no we wouldn't lock you into anything
that's a relief how long for delivery
i've got a conjugal visit next week
well what if i don't have to shave that
often
no problem after you sign up you can
choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
i like that ew
what's this i hear about dollar shave
club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like dr cover
shave butter boogie's hair gel and
big cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up with dollar shave club so join the
club today
[Music]
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it linkedin facebook or
instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that burger king video
advertising that new whopper
or about a marketing tool that can help
you visualize your team's workload
better than any other in the market
right now now these are just some of the
many ways that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them
now alongside publishing quality content
it also involves analyzing your data
and running social media advertisements
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are facebook
instagram twitter linkedin and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness
now with the help of interactions with
people on social media brands are able
to build up their reputation as a
business
and with each interaction each post each
share the brand is exposed to a larger
network of potential customers who might
be interested in the products or
services offered
next it gets you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website
outside your usual customer base
next it improves your brand's search
engine rankings now although this isn't
a direct correlation
social media marketing does have a part
to play when it comes to helping your
page rank higher up in search engine
rankings now if you start posting high
quality content
people will start liking and sharing it
this will in turn bring it to the
attention of influencers within the
industry who will be willing to write
about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting your brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compassion
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective now compared to other forms of
digital marketing
social media marketing offers some of
the most flexible and relatively low
cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures now
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your authority
you can have your followers look up to
you now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind the goal
of your marketing strategy will be the
driving force behind every decision that
you make
now this is exactly why setting up goals
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative
for example you need to have thousand
conversions by the end of the quarter or
5000 followers on instagram by the end
of the month and so on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives wait for
each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now
smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and time
based
now let's go to number four
like i mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the not star metric
now what is the not star metric
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this north star metric will also give
your team clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
not stars
there's increased engagement greater
conversion rates more leads generated
app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for now
there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them
the age demographics of your audience by
conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments on blogs
and social media
taking up their feedbacks or suggestions
into consideration and acting on them
and so on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we taken our personal example
here is simply learn now simply learns
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the baiju's app
has high school students as users
now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now when selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform
who you'll reach with this platform
what content would work best on the
platform and is there any content that
was unique to that platform for example
youtube and then there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you now
while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones there's
linkedin facebook instagram and
pinterest
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms now linkedin is a
professional network that's best suited
for b2b audiences
now for facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually find success on
facebook
then we have instagram
visual content works best on instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have pinterest pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
a social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience
it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media
first off we have competitions
now i'm sure all of you have seen posts
like tag a friend who does this or
comment or like to win something and
stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience now they can be used to
encourage your followers to share your
content it could be also for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media
then we have polls or service
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams
now although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
now these help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and so
much more to offer
live stream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business humanizes your brand and by
extension helps increase customer
loyalty and trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process
you can plan create and schedule posts
on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer hootsuite bus
sumo if triple t and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to
creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of posts
now for number six
visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information in the simplest
of forms
visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it
this can help your audience stay
interested and engaged grab the
attention of potential clients and so
much more
but it also has some other advantages
it helps you build a bond with your
audience
visual storytelling connects with your
methods like live streaming help
humanize your brand and help grow
customer loyalty and trust
it helps the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature
and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
now here's what is machine learning data
science in 5 minutes and ai in 5 minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our channel
and now you know why
visual storytelling
if you guys are interested in watching
these videos you can check them out on
our channel home page we also have
similar videos about blockchain devops
and six sigma
now
back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach
and improve your brand's visibility
its pay-per-click model ensures cost
effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investment it also
helps improve targeting by letting you
control who sees your ad you get to
choose from a number of different
factors like interests hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic user demographics like age
location gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
refine the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content disregarding it in
the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have an uphill battle to deal with
better funded organizations
next we have number eight news jacking
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness
news jacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand
it also helps shine a spotlight on your
products it also helps you show off that
you are up to date with current events
in the industry and that your product is
relevant
by extension it also improves engagement
and website traffic
now for number nine
a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media
now since audiences would react
differently depending on the content a b
testing helps determine which of the
variants your audience engaged with the
most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location
age gender education your audience
interests and so on
next up number 10
community and influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
now actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in youtube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influences
we have marcus brownlee unbox therapy mr
who's the boss and linus tech tips
each of them with more than 4 million
subscribers
and finally we're at number 11
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on twitter you could look
out for impressions
clicks and impressions and interactions
on linkedin
likes comments and mentions on instagram
and engagement and impressions on
pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are sprout social buffer
hootsuite google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness
trust and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand
to increase traffic to your site and get
more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress
they'll help you with increased
collaboration greater support run a b
test and much more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one re-market your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
binder audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position zero enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it tend to follow solo influencers
they advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you're
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five
back up your arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable
this will also help your brand grow as
an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you do you guys
have any tips for content marketing that
we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
all right so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly it can help you create
value built content and fix pain points
faced by your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience it
provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to site media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 of them felt content marketing
was really important to their digital
marketing campaigns and more than 25 of
their budgets are used for visual
advertising content like images
infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content instagram
and pinterest for visual content twitter
for smaller snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience now like i mentioned
earlier your marketing campaign isn't
going to bear fruit without targeting a
specific audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content one of the best ways to build
your audience is to get people or
influencers who already share content
within your niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience there would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean who is
subscribing to your emails who do you
already have in your email database and
you can look at social media i mean you
look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interest so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it signs that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature
that's part of that product that you
offer then that's the segment you're
going to be writing about so you need to
collect your data on your audience ahead
of time and then you're going to segment
that audience okay so you're not going
to write content for everyone because
the shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone okay the shoe has to fit for
specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest i mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new re users versus
returning users it could be users who
are purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be an
age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
google analytics you just got to go in
the analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
br it's age is broken out by age range
and then you'll see gender so you're
going to see a breakdown of gender and
use that to your advantage so if you're
going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by men versus women and then you can
see again same thing as google analytics
you could see an age range breakout you
could use twitter analytics i mean
twitter has share some really good
insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on linkedin you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to target are c-level meaning
ceos
or cfos or cmos you know chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even vps so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now i know this sounds like a
given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's gonna result
in a lot of things are gonna benefit you
you know one you're gonna come across as
you know somebody who knows what they're
talking about and that's gonna help
increase your brand awareness okay when
you increase your brand awareness people
know about you so it's likely going to
increase traffic to your website or if
you're on social media you know if you
produce good high quality content people
are gonna share that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether that's a video or blog post or
or infographic you know people are going
to become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword plan or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention okay so give valuable content
to readers and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points change so these are all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes
you know you need to avoid those there's
no reason for grammatical mistakes
today's technology doesn't allow for it
and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know so break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a b test baby test so important
why because with a b split testing you
can increase your conversion rates okay
so four elements to test in your content
marketing strategy so if you have
content say a blog and you're testing
that blog you know test out the images
test out the forms do you have a long
form or short form you know test out the
content length you can have a variation
that is a lot shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
your call to actions do matter you know
do you want to use a softer call to
action a softer tone or do you want to
use something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the closer to purchasing and
through that funnel so a b testing to me
is something that should be naturally
done with google optimize it's free so
with images you know you could test a
lot of different variations of images
anything from people to
you know outlandish imagery to just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is gonna
stick with that time on page but on your
a b test create something maybe a little
longer if it's engaging enough maybe
somebody's gonna stay a little bit
longer on the page so you know create a
variation it's gonna play with that
length okay so use analytics to your
advantage to figure out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does
matter don't use red use green people
react to different colors but again you
have cultural variances as well so you
got to take that into account if you're
in the middle east or the far east asia
you know color schemes and what you say
matters and it changes versus say you
know europe or the west okay so keep
that in mind when you're making changes
on color or tone or placement and things
of that nature so you want to conduct a
competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics you know
looking at your audience you're doing
all this work you might as well take the
next step and figure out what it is your
competitors are doing so you can opt for
competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search uh sem rush or
moz or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are seo platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these seo platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
i say official route with an e-book or
case study something that a user is
going to be able to take away with maybe
download okay something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that it's not a
blog post it's an ebook now if you're
into talking like i am then you can
certainly do a podcast and podcasts are
always popular depending on the topic so
you got to be aware of the topic now
videos are always always a good option
you got the likes of video
and video and youtube and some other you
know video platforms out there that
allow you the ability to get found very
quickly especially with the likes of
youtube you know people use youtube
before they go on to purchasing a
product so think about that so if you're
trying to get somebody if you're trying
to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal
you know customer to taking the next
step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so and it
shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded in and you
solving that customer's problem so the
case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for a certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your target audience or
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or what you could do
is if you know who your loyal customers
are you target them with a promotional
email so there's lots of ways to slice
and dice content via email okay just
make sure you know your target audience
is there's lots of things you can do in
email again you can complement lots of
different formats within email as i
mentioned before with a podcast or a
blog post so keep all that in mind email
is a good way to communicate with your
audience okay the last point we want to
make here is use native ads okay so we
talk about native ads it's one of the
smartest ways to connect your audience
with your brand so for example this is a
native ad on buzzfeed okay it's about 15
bands that probably wouldn't exist
without led zeppelin okay so for you
folks out there that don't know who led
zeppelin is a rock group from the 70s
late 60s 70s okay disbanded in 80 81 82
early 80s okay but you know people grew
up like myself listening to led zeppelin
okay so you can see the headline here 15
bands that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
to say the headline or led zeppelin per
se but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 more likely to look at a native ad
than at a banner and so that native ad
in this case we're talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music just music in general might
get enough to get peak people's interest
okay so if you're going to create
content you know align that content with
something that's you know naturally
going to fit and that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that they're associated with so
finally after all that's said and done
when all you've done is create good
content follow up via emails targeting
your audience and associating that
content with you know content natively
then you can always measure your content
performance so
my favorite part of it all you go into
analytics going to facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the case study received again
with the video you want to measure video
views now if you're packaging up emails
and sending them out to your target
audience you want to make sure you look
at open rates and click rates okay so a
lot of things you can be looking at so
make sure you choose the right metrics
because there's hundreds and hundreds of
metrics to choose from so just be aware
all the different metrics that are
available you know if you're in it for
search okay how much traffic getting
from search where are you ranking so
there are a lot of things you need to
think about so think about the content
that you're producing and think about
how you want to be able to measure that
content so let's go back over our
checklist here
so what you could do is create an
editorial calendar in fact i would
highly suggest you create an editorial
calendar in order to keep track of all
the content you've done over a period of
time are you making your content worth
reading that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
wanna you know make sure you're reusing
or using or adding to the content that
you've created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
facebook you know leverage the feedback
you get from facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means seo so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
right audience whether that be young
middle-aged or older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadatas title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even all tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up in search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search okay
so you want to create a detailed summary
and title and again that goes along with
the title tag meta description and then
you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and comment on
your blog so don't be afraid like i'm
gonna do right now in this video is if
i'm missing anything from this checklist
feel free to comment hey i've written my
fair share content but i could be
talking to an audience that is just as
qualified as i am
and they may have some tips so feel free
to comment underneath this video now
don't be afraid to ask just like i just
did people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a content box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so one know your
audience again you can lean on google
analytics you know demographic data
whether it be age or gender you could do
the same with facebook and twitter and
linkedin you know every platform has
some data you could take away create
high quality content when i mean high
quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running to maybe test you know run some
variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like semrush and moz all you got to do
is plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about
where a particular competitor ranks for
keyword or how many backlinks and what
websites are linking to them so all
that's available in these seo platforms
okay so you want to choose a suitable
content format we listed a few from
ebooks to case studies to podcasts to
infographics to blog posts to videos
it's up to you what you think is best
for your audience just keep in mind you
need to be able to measure it and so
that's the important thing if it doesn't
work the first time out then you might
want to consider changing out the
content format choose a content
management system you know plenty out
there wordpress is a good one if you're
going to be a blogger okay blogging
allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so you
know if you created a video you know put
that video in the form of an email and
send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it
line your kpis so if it's an e-book or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people are actually
downloading them okay if it's a video
how many people like the video how many
people are commenting how many people
are sharing the video how many people
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from wordpress to youtube to
reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing
you're doing some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends in an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing designing
the website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything
or any planning or any strategy around
bringing users to your website so the
two go hand in hand you just can't build
a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or
you can earn revenue through sponsored
posts and advertisements so if you have
for example a lot of content on your
website you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth so
having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you gotta get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads it's one of
the easiest ways to drive traffic to
your website so some of the options
available are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so
for example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobraio
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad
then it's going to be more visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so
that's paid advertising again through
search through social through display
but you can also promote your site on
social media so once your content has
gone live you could take advantage of
different social media platforms i mean
it really depends on what you're trying
to promote because what you're trying to
promote needs to align with the
appropriate social media platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or ecommerce
then you can also leverage instagram
which is part of facebook's ecosystem so
if you advertise on facebook you can
also advertise on instagram and or
instagram so it doesn't have to be and
facebook and instagram it could be
facebook or instagram you also have
linkedin as a platform linkedin is great
for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest post blogging so
most you already know what blogging is
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for surfs
because it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging is a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
an effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because google
is going to recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media following because you
can then promote that on social media
that you're guest blogging okay again
you can improve your online authority
okay because when you're guest blogging
and you have recognition on that guest
blog if it's a popular blog then it's
gonna help your domain and page
authority for seo and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in
and it allows you to engage with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms and that could in turn drive
traffic to your website obviously just
like guest blogging it's going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there nobody knows who your brand is
and they know who the thought leaders
are and they say you're interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people and so it's
going to increase your reach another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that person
is looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjust
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
brand's all about it's about identifying
your brand with other people okay and
identify people who identify with your
brand and messaging and talking to them
as if they're part of your own community
your own family so you can use user
generated content that provides future
marketing strategies so the feedback you
get from your own community could be in
turn used to promote or used in future
marketing strategies i.e advertising i.e
post on social okay it can also provide
pr opportunities so it's a chance for
you
to
you know put out press releases based on
the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the
what they deserve the respect and
loyalty that they deserve as well
because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is be active in the comment section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se it could be other
sites like reddit or cora or media sites
that have a lot of content that are
broken out by industry that allow you to
engage in conversation allow you to
either upvote or share
or respond okay so be active because
when you're active people are going to
see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chances are somebody's
going to click on your listing and it
provides increased engagement and
traffic and so what that means is more
traffic more engagement an engagement is
something you define it could be again a
download of a document or the clicking
on the play button of a video or or
submitting a form or signing up for a
newsletter or calling these are all
forms of engagement so the the amount of
traffic you drive from organic search to
your website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
and improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so if somebody's looking for
a pair of red women's nike shoes the
2019 model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with seo we want to be able to
build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page and so off page involves
backlinking so backlinks are just links
that direct users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
backlinking because it's an off page
strategy why is it an off page seo
strategy because if google
crawls that other site that has a link
to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust this site so
by google trusting your site it's going
to improve your organic ranking and with
the organic rankings being approved
meaning it's going to mean faster
indexing so what does that mean so you
want to be indexed by the search engines
and so the quicker google can find your
pages even if it's on somebody else's
site then that means they're going to
follow that link go to that page on your
site and take that page back to their
servers to be indexed okay so the
quicker you can get index the quicker
you get found and then it helps with
referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credit from an seo perspective
from an internal linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has really good relevance in
the eyes of google then the other page
is probably going to benefit from that
the other reason you want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply the rate at which people land on
a page and then leave so if i have 100
people land on my homepage and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and when we buy link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so they're usually three or longer
keywords in a phrase okay so long tail
keywords really nowadays account for
most web searches people
really take the time to even pose
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red nike running shoes 2019 or some
variation of that okay that's a long
tail keyword and some of the advantages
of using long tail keywords to be found
for are less competition so if you're
using broad keywords like red shoes then
who doesn't want to be found for red
shoes well you don't necessarily you
don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too bright so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
gonna be greater and the chances of you
ranking faster are gonna be greater and
then of course if somebody's looking for
exactly what you have to offer
then you have a higher chance to convert
that person so if you have exactly those
2019 red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases
what it also does is brings targeted
traffic so even if somebody doesn't
convert hey they could be back because
it's exactly what they're looking for
and if you're focusing on longer tail
keywords like i just mentioned stay away
from the shorter ones it's just easier
to optimize your page for seo so
remember seo is a two-pronged approach
on-page and off-page we talked about
off-page with internal linking and
backlinks on-page is all about making
sure those keywords you choose are
integrated in with the page you want to
be found for and so if you're using a
long tail keyword it's just easy to work
that keyword in so it enables easier
page optimization
okay let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so let's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your
email's targeted if it's targeted it
could be cost effective why because
sending large amounts of emails or let's
just say an email to a large amount of
people or a large group of people is
going to be cost effective it's not cost
per click you know it's not cost per
open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so it just really depends
on how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so that's normally what happens in email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email
again as long as you're not sending an
email on a daily basis normally most
companies send it monthly or bi-weekly
it's not going to be as intrusive okay
and then it also helps build credibility
increased visibility and brand awareness
meaning you're going to build your brand
in that email you're going to put
content in that email that's going to
show off your credibility meaning you
could put some testimonials in the email
you could put some good affiliations you
can put a good article to an industry
article you just wrote so email is going
to inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so
why do we recommend webinars well
because it provides direct content
contact within your target group
what do we mean by contact with your
target group well you're gonna host a
webinar and you're gonna invite this
targeted group of people who are
interested in your product or service so
if you have a facebook community you
could do a facebook live event or you
could do a youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or or roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get built
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then it's chances
are they're going to
share
that particular video which is going to
bode well for your brand and traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video especially
from a mobile phone so youtube just
makes it so easy to share or like or
subscribe to a channel it just it
becomes that much easier things can go
viral and chances of them going viral
with video are going to be greater okay
so other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
reddit people are either going to upvote
it or downvote it so the more upvotes
you get or thumbs up or likes or people
who encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a social post or
blog post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on quora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking then people are going
to react to it and then that again could
lead to traffic but even if it doesn't
lead to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there and when you put content out
there it's only gonna especially if it's
good content put it's gonna put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic seo brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics so i have to do is
just go to google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and while they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or they coming from organic
search it is so google analytics can
help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our seo efforts
and then with google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by page by language
by city by region i mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information in analytics if that's your
target audience then you could see how
they're performing okay so anal there
are a lot of benefits to google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take advantage of the data
that google analytics or any other
analytics platform is giving you by
learning once you learn what's going on
with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the leads she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers okay so customers
sign up but they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do so how's she gonna
solve the problem of converting the lead
she gets into paying customers well look
no further than email market so you can
boost your sales funnel with the help of
email marketing so email marketing leads
to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing
email markings also and a it's a very
good way to generate a high return on
investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your telling me is a very efficient way
to generate a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so linda is now
very interested we've peaked her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening
what's in it for you why are you going
to invest your time and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because we're going to talk
about everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're going to talk about how to set up
email marketing we're going to discuss
all the benefits of email marketing
we're going to get into a b testing
we're going to get into the automation
of emails the types of emails how to
engage new users and we're going to give
you a demo so there's a lot going on in
this webinar like i said buckle up and
let's get started and talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our products we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to re-market pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or
not sure what products to buy you know
an email can cover that okay the next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin perfect skin moisturizer
smooths hydrates and contains spf 20. so
we got the perfect product for that
person who's further along the funnel
and really is ready to purchase that
product so we can hit that person up
with the perfect messaging to talk about
purchase the next step in the lifecycle
well purchase well with purchase we can
send an email that encourages that
customer purchase our product by
offering them something okay by giving
an offer for example we can give a
discount discounts always tend to work
so that moisturizer that that particular
customer was considering buying well
they can move from consideration to
purchasing because we're going to offer
them a discount they can't refuse okay
so you know it could beat for a specific
date okay it could be you know something
that's going to get them excited to buy
the product 20 off of moisturizers
pretty good deal and especially if that
percentage off is better than the other
products that we're considering buying
so getting somebody that extra incentive
to purchase the product goes a long way
via email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in our inventory so what do we
do we're going to send an email we're
going to send an email to active
customers okay we're going to give them
an offer just for them exclusively just
for them in this example we're gonna
give them a combo pack a facial kit at
just 39 and get a sunscreen worth ten
dollars for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers key is
the offer is exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that they help they help the
environment they help the needy okay
they care and so we can go ahead and
provide a call to action for these
customers that are loyal to our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word on you know
what we're trying to accomplish for our
nonprofit or if anything just get them
to promote it maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be you know just sharing
with friends it can be that extra
incentive of giving them a discount if
they do share with friends and their
friends by okay so this is the customer
life cycle and examples of different
emails that you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about the benefits of email
marketing so what are some of the
benefits well we've already mentioned to
linda that it's cost effective it's time
saving real time marketing
less intrusive builds credibility
increases visibility and brand awareness
and it's an easy way to track roi these
are all the benefits for email marketing
we're gonna go talk about some of these
now so basically when we talk about cost
effective you know some email marketing
platforms charge based on the number of
users who you send the email to time
saving well you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
when we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs at the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw i can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but roi so how many people
from that email went on and purchased so
we can measure that it's very easy to
measure email today we're going to talk
about affiliate marketing so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have chuck here chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing john walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right chuck
responded hey i'm just worried that i
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product i mean i've done
seo i've done paid search i've done
email i've done social man nothing's
working i gotta come up with something
new asap well john responds hey don't
worry i think i've got your solution for
you man hang tight
relax take a load off here's my solution
affiliate marketing first off before you
ask the question what's affiliate
marketing let's talk about why we need
affiliate marketing so let's dig into
affiliate marketing so john's just
taking over now and he's gonna let chuck
know everything there is to know about
affiliate marketing so the first
question john answers for chuck what is
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if i'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me i'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
john's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away john so
john says first we have the merchant aka
the brand the seller the creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea this
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups to large multinational
companies international companies
non-profits for-profits individuals
independent contractors freelancers a
group of people who have a passion for
something okay it could be anybody
there's no limit the affiliate aka the
publisher so the affiliate is basically
that third-party website or entity which
promotes the merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchant's product's value so this
is going to represent the merchant on
their behalf and try and get their
clients to basically purchase that
particular merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if i'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey i can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if i've got this big you know
offline you know promotion that i'm
doing at this particular mall and i want
to get people there well i can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that merchant who has
this brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially
drive registrations sales signups etc to
the merchant so the affiliate network is
the one who brings the two together so
the affiliate network in effect acts as
the middleman the person in between the
merchants and affiliates it allows
merchants to find and collaborate with
not just any affiliate but the affiliate
best suited for their particular brand
and product because you want to find
somebody who is going to be passionate
who's relevant who has your prospective
customers in mind because they're the
ones that are going to help those
protective customers purchase your
product so that's what the affiliate
network does it helps bring the
merchants and affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate network merchants can
use tools for tracking and reporting and
processing payments for affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant an
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
john so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so john what is the
process
of affiliate marketing well john says
let's have a look at the process so it's
affiliate marketing time so we're gonna
use a tool or platform like commission
junction commission junction is a
popular you know platform that
affiliate network platform that brings
merchants and affiliates together so the
merchants can use those affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at
commission junction as a good digital
marketing tool for affiliate marketing
so we're going to use commission
junction as an example here remember an
affiliate marketing it's an ecosystem
between
publishers
and merchants so remember merchants are
selling products publishers are selling
those merchant products on their site
and so commission junction is the
middleman so to speak okay so commission
junction just known as cj now is the
middle person they're introducing the
publisher and the merchant and so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product
you obviously want somebody who's
relevant somebody who's going to be able
to sell a product somebody who has a
targeted audience that's similar to
yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
publisher's link so we're going to click
on the publishers link and remember when
you sign up publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember
you could set up your own program term
for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here
we can't or these publishers can't make
any money if they don't generate clicks
so that's why you have an epc model or
metric so to speak so you can measure
earnings per click cj does it over seven
day period and over a three month period
so you could sort based on seven day or
three month to see who's earning the
most per click in terms of publishers
now you can select under publishers
groups now you can group your publishers
okay so if you have say a group of
publishers in a specific region like the
united states or india or if you're just
focused on the united states and say you
have publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers in two
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so
as you get more publishers for your
network you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get publishers you want
to start building your base of
publishers because the more publishers
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's gonna buy
your product so if you have publishers
who are promoting your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers now when
you're in cj and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publishers so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling cj is going to try and
put you in front of
some good publishers and so here we
could see if we click on recruit we're
going to get a list of publishers and
this search results list of publishers
that we can recruit into our network are
all listed here and you can actually see
what's interesting you can see the name
of the publisher and you can see the url
and then you could actually see
if they're a good performer or not so
you could actually see their history as
a publisher just by looking at their
network earnings and then also looking
at their seven day earnings per click or
three month earnings per click and so
if a publisher has a very high earnings
per click epc then they're probably a
good publisher somebody you're probably
going to be interested in so if i see
a publisher with you know three month
earnings per click of 105
then that means hey if that's my
publisher i'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me i want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these publishers and so i can just click
on any one of these publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in cj so
here i can see the particular url the
company some other urls that they have
associated with them in cj i can see the
category that they're in again i can see
the seven three month epc here you can
see description okay you can see some
other promotional methods that they'd
use when promoting products and you get
some permanent performance from this
particular publisher just by pulling
down the pull down menu here i'm going
to look at this year and see what their
performance is and why i'm waiting for
that to load i could see hey they're
also in other countries as well so i can
get a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
publishers seeing what their performance
is over a period of time and potentially
you know recruiting that publisher to be
part of my network because if they're
part of my network then hey if they're
selling products if i'm selling products
and i want my product on their site and
they're doing a good job of selling
other products then i want them to be
you know part of my ecosystem part of my
network now remember
cj's doing the introducing here they're
introducing you to recruits so
you want to be able to again take a look
at the site does do any of the sites
that a particular publisher has
interest you you know again we can just
click on it go to the specific site take
a good look hey virgin atlantic okay do
we want them selling our product maybe
maybe not um so you want to take a look
at the website make sure it's not spammy
make sure it aligns with your business
goals it makes your aligns with your
product your target audience remember a
lot of things you want to make sure the
website aligns with because they're
representing your brand okay very
important here very important and so
that's what you want to be able to do
and you could do all that just by
looking at the publisher detail in cg
and then again take a look at earnings
per click if they're selling products
for other merchants and they're doing a
good job maybe you want them selling
your product as well okay so you can
also you know sort by country
you can also do network earnings and you
can really filter here so we want you
know choose high network earners in a
particular country a particular state
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to align
with your geography or you know
definitely you want to align with
somebody who's a high network owner now
when you get all your publishers set up
you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners um you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the publishers with you know the
information they need now
as a best practice remember you can get
on the phone with these publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the cj platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so
if i click on links here and manage i'll
be able to see everything that i have
available for my publishers to use okay
and then you can actually look at
banners that have actually produced for
you in terms of epc or
you know if it's a specific promotion
okay you could set that up here so
you're going to be able to see it here
you can see all the banners you can see
some text links in here so all the you
know advertising that you want these
publishers to have is going to be
situated under links and so you can see
what the active ones are you can look at
archived you can look at again text
links content links or banners and as a
best practice if i click on a banner as
a best practice ideally what you want to
do is use utm tracking okay so you want
to have some type of tracking in place
however
cj does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times a banner has been clicked and
how many times a banner's been seen okay
they'll also tell you more importantly
not only was that banner click but did
it generate a sale and so here i can see
that i have three publishers using this
particular banner i can see over this
period of time 412 impressions meaning
412 people viewed the banner and i
received one click on it so you can get
some in-depth detail about your
different marketing materials and how
they're performing okay you can also see
what publishers are using them okay so
the key here is
you want to be able to communicate with
your publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up a
unique banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what i would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
got a 160 by 600 you got a 300 by 250.
okay so you want to have different
banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text um ads as well okay you want
to be able to give
your publishers some options in terms of
what to use on their websites so that's
the whole idea because a publisher may
not have space on the home page they may
only have enough space for you know a
text ad or a 300 by 250. so you want to
be able to mix it up and then also mix
up the messaging as well so you can have
the same 300 250 banner but you can have
different messaging just like you see
here 300 by 250 got this messaging here
and we got a different set of messaging
with the same banner size so the more
options you present for yourself the
more of an opportunity you have for the
publisher to use that messaging that
banner that text that on their website
and then that gives you a better
opportunity to get the click get the
conversion that you seek out so
that is links so you want to be able to
continue to
push out different banners and text ads
now cj also has a great feature in here
if you're selling a lot of products you
have a large inventory of products you
could actually upload a product feed to
cj so you can see in this example we
don't but
if you did let's just say you have a
hundred products that you want to sell
you can go ahead and upload that fee to
cj and then the publisher will be able
to use that entirety in its of the feed
or pick and choose different products to
use and sell so let's jump over to
reports and cj you have reports so this
is really the bulk of where you want to
be spending your time because you want
to be able to
you know not only recruit those
publishers but after you recruit them
you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving or are
publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
product so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see
over a period of time you know are we
selling our product and here you can see
over the last 30 days you could see how
much commission was paid out remember cj
gets a fee they're the broker okay so
that's part of the program terms okay so
it's based on program terms who's
selling okay what program term are they
associated with cj gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many impressions so i
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now i can go into detail
if i click on transaction here from the
pull down menu i can look at a specific
order i can choose a specific publisher
or website and i can get details about
that specific order publisher website
etc just be look by choosing transaction
so i can get really granular about the
data i see for a specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now we can also click on
promo codes and if you're running any
promo codes for your publishers you'll
be able to see
how many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the set total sale amount
over the last 30 days so building a
network is all about recruiting the
right publishers
giving them the materials they need
measuring the performance of the
publishers and then communicating it's
just so key so cj has a nice message
center built in so you can actually you
know look at the messages you're getting
from your publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so
communicate
seamlessly and efficiently right in cj
here so i just clicked on mail and we
can see the messages we have so you can
also click on email campaigns and if you
have any email campaigns that you want
to run you can look at them right here
in cj so cj offers up some email
campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our network
so
here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries etc so if
you want to run an email campaign write
in cj it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a publisher's website and so
here we could see a breakdown of
different publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher saying hey i
have a creative the placement is a home
page banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on placements and we'll be able
to see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to
reward a publisher that's performing
well for you and if they turn around and
offer you a better placement for a
little bit more money it might be worth
it so the whole idea is to take
advantage of placements because if your
product is in place properly then
nobody's gonna see it if nobody sees it
then you know they're not gonna click on
it and then you're not gonna get sales
so that's the whole idea here
is take advantage of what publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so cj also has a
pay-per-call
click uh model as well pay model so
basically
your pay per performance is based on
calls so
basically the whole point here is as cj
points out you want to promote more high
ticket and consultative products and
services you want to expand your reach
and you want to get more qualified sales
then you can offer up a pay per call and
the beauty here is cj tracks the calls
so
you will be able to see
the actual phone number and calls so
instead of offering up say you know
banner with a click you can offer up you
know promotional number and have cj
tracked the calls from the publisher and
that just opens up another opportunity
for you to give your publishers an
option to have people call if they call
then great you know it's another way for
somebody to get in touch and purchase
the product so the pay-per-call method
is available under cj as well so if we
want to get more insights about how our
program is performing we just click on
the insights cj's gonna take us to this
overview this dashboard if you will with
some really good data based on a time
frame okay so we're comparing july
through
of july of 19 through july of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks average order
value so
there's kind of an overview dashboard if
you will about
how our overall program is performing
there are other similar tools and
resources to include you know max bounty
trade doubler amazon associates there's
plenty of networks out there you want to
find a network where
you're going to have affiliates that are
going to be passionate and going to be
relevant and have the prospective
audience that you need to sell your
product so do your due diligence on the
number of different platforms out there
hey guys welcome to this video in this
session we'll be covering some of the
most important marketing books for
entrepreneurs
digital marketing is a field that will
probably never go out of style and
thanks to this there's always going to
be people searching for new innovations
and techniques to make the process
easier which means that alongside
courses tutorials and your own work
experience you will need a little more
to bring about true innovation
that's where marketing book comes in
so let's ask the most important question
probably on your mind why should i be
reading these books
the marketing books that we are going to
talk about here and the marketing books
in general are a collection of data and
experiences from goliaths within the
industry
these books provide a window to the time
period they were written in and help you
understand how marketing is still in
some ways extremely similar to how
things were back then albeit with more
technology nowadays
you will also soon see that the books
that we revere the most when it comes to
marketing are the ones that were written
in the period of the early 60s to 90s
an era where the lives we live now would
have been impossible to imagine that's
what makes these books so special the
time period and some of the methods may
have changed by the concepts and rules
covered in these books have stood the
test of time and are timeless let's now
start with number 12 contagious by jana
berger
a new york times bestseller this book is
perfect for someone looking to
understand how to spread ideas
increase brand awareness or even to grow
their customer base
it goes on to explain why certain ideas
products and stories get shared and grow
in popularity
why only certain emails and videos get
forwarded and much more
contagious also goes into detail about
the six basic principles that contribute
to content becoming viral or contagious
from products initiatives youtube videos
and more
it also provides actionable and specific
techniques to spread information
designing messages and more
now let's talk about jana berger he's a
marketing professor at the wharton
school at the university of pennsylvania
he's an expert in concepts like word of
mouth how consumer behavior can be
influenced how stories ideas
and products catch on and much more he's
also been a keynote speaker in several
prominent events and consults companies
like google apple nike and more
now let's have a look at number 11
hooked by neral
this book called a critical work in the
field of psychological marketing is one
that delves into how habit-forming
products can be built
years of analyzing startups have led nir
to understand the customers can be
influenced
this led to the creation of the hook
model
this book talks about how the hook model
which is a four step process can enable
companies to subtly encourage particular
customer behavior
it also provides practical insights into
how the hook can be used to create user
habits that will get them further booked
onto your product
the book also provides steps to create
such a product
finally the book also provides examples
as to how companies like iphone twitter
and pinterest hook the users
now let's talk about nirail
starting off his career in the gaming
and advertising industry nir created
different techniques through which he
could motivate and manipulate users he
also helps create behaviors that can
benefit users while educating people to
build healthy habits
he is also an active angel investor in
companies like canva everbright kahoot
and more
now for number 10 we have the conversion
code by chris smith
this book recommended by digital
marketing guru neil patel is one that
focuses on helping users to increase
sales in this internet driven era
it guides users on tips to perform
online lead generation and inside sales
it also details the many ways companies
can engage with their consumers bait
media mobile apps and blogs and how to
be effective at it
the book also focuses on leveraging the
strengths of social media apps and blogs
to capture more leads for less money
like i mentioned earlier the main focus
in this book is to convert more internet
leads into real-world prospects and
sales appointments
let's now talk about smith he's a
best-selling author and co-founder of a
blog called curator which is a social
media digital marketing and coaching
company
his work has been featured in a number
of major publications like adweek and
forbes he is also an in-demand keynote
speaker and is often on real estate
industrialists as one of the most
influential people within the industry
next up number nine
designing brand entity by alina wheeler
called a comprehensive pragmatic and
easy to understand resource for brand
builders by the global brand leader of
deloitte
this book mainly focuses on the
fundamentals processes and case studies
behind creating a brand
it covers more than 100 branding
subjects checklists tools and diagrams
the book also acts as a companion for
tools that can make the branding process
a success and some of the best practices
that will get you some inspiration
the book also has 50 case studies
describing goals processes strategies
solutions and results
now
let's talk about the author alina
wheeler alina wheeler is a prominent
speaker who guides teams with everything
brand related
from brand fundamentals processes
best practices and much more she's also
been coaching business leaders and
design consultancies
and has worked with more than 100
companies within the private and public
sector
now let's go to number eight gets crappy
by nick westgard
called the digital marketing bible by
publishers weekly this book helps
smaller companies with lesser resources
to develop powerhouse results
it also aims to help teams to think like
underdogs and to leverage the right
social networks and the appropriate
digital marketing tools
and to effectively reach people
it also focuses on integrating the
marketing strategy across touch points
for a unified brand experience both
online and off
now let's talk about the author nick
westgard
nick has helped brands grow from small
businesses fortune 500 companies to
president obama's jobs council
he's also a regular contributor to the
harvard business review us news and
world report
entrepreneur
forbes
mashable and more he is also a member of
the boards of the university of iowa
school of journalism and mass
communication
the iowa city area chamber of commerce
and film scene
next we have number seven
how to win friends and influence people
in the digital age by dale
published in 1936
the book has been number 8 on the list
of the top checkouts of all time by new
york public library
despite its age the many concepts are
still relevant and have been updated to
fit modern requirements
the book lays out powerful and timeless
principles of human communications that
have impacted millions
the essentials of engagement affirming
what's good connecting with core desires
and other concepts are elaborated on
the book also explains how to make a
lasting impression to merit and maintain
trust in how to lead change
now
let's talk about dale carnegie
he's a writer and lecturer and the
developer of courses dealing with
self-improvement salesmanship corporate
training public speaking interpersonal
skills and much more by the time of
carnegie's death in 1955 his book had
sold 5 million copies in 31 languages
and there had been 4 lakh 50 000
graduates of his dale carnegie institute
now for number six
positioning by al riese and jack trout
this book released in 2001 called one of
the most popular marketing books ever
released still keeps up with the current
marketing landscape
it details how brands can make their
product an industry leader it explains
strategies that can capture a large
market share and to build their
strategies around the competitors
weaknesses
the book also helps to analyze and
incorporate data from trends
now let's talk about already and jack
trout
already is an author and marketing
professional credited with resurrecting
the idea of positioning in marketing
jack trout was a marketer who was one of
the founders and pioneers of marketing
warfare theory and positioning theory
next for number five epic content
marketing by joe polizzi
this book called one of fortune
magazine's top 5 business book
must reads explains how to attract
customers and lead them to your
businesses by creating relevant content
the book helps determine what your
brand's content niche is
and what you need to do to keep their
attention
the book can help discover and develop
your content marketing mission statement
and to set up a process to create and
curate content
it also explains how to leverage social
media and email channels to create and
grow your audience
now let's talk about joe polizzi he's an
author and an authority when it comes to
content marketing
he founded the content marketing
institute and launched several events
one among them being content marketing
world
he also won the 2014 john caldwell
lifetime achievement award by the
content council
next up we have number four crushing it
by gary vaynerhook
a new york times bestseller this book
helps people build a personal brand and
how to achieve their goals
the book explains the many ways social
media platforms can be taken advantage
of by organizations to make a personal
brand for themselves
it provides tricks and tweaks to enhance
these strategies
it also provides tactical and
theoretical advice on how to become a
star on social media and podcast
services
it also details examples from real life
scenarios and how they were handled
let's talk about gary vinhoek
he's an investor and advisor for several
startups across the world he's also an
expert on fortune 500 companies
he also runs vaynermedia a digital
marketing agency that helps companies
like ge pepsico hasbro the new york jets
and more
now for number three a girl way on
advertising by david or kelvin this book
written by david ogilvy who was known as
the most sought after wizard in the
industry by time magazine was released
in 1983.
this consists of concepts that remain
valid to this day it covers a number of
different facets of advertising and
covers the four foundational principles
of advertising
it also covers the author's experiences
working with many prominent brands of
the era
let's take a look at david ogilvy
he was a british advertising tycoon
and the founder of ogilvy and mathur
he was called the father of advertising
he introduced the concept of branding to
advertising and focused on the
importance of the creative copy and
campaign themes
now for number two
the 22 immutable laws of marketing by
already and jack trout
this book covers 22 innovative rules
that help with understanding and
succeeding in an international
marketplace
the book provides insight into several
concepts that are still relevant today
it also details 22 superlative tools and
innovative techniques for the
international marketplace
and now for number one
scientific advertising by claude c
hopkins
this book released in 1923 has been
cited as the mastery book by several
advertising personalities like david
ogilvy gary halbert and jay abraham
it's credited with providing the
original description for split testing
and copen based customer tracking and
loyalty programs
it also details an advertising approach
that ensures reduced losses from
unsuccessful ads and gains from
profitable ads are multiplied
now
let's talk about the author claude c
hopkins
he was known as an advertising pioneer
and was known as leader in the creation
and development of modern day consumer
brand advertising and direct response
marketing
he was inducted into the advertising
hall of fame in 1957. now let's get
started with marketing hacks
first you need to make personalized
messages
one of the most important things you
need to make sure of is that you
understand your audience
things like what they expect from your
brand what products they are interested
in what they like what they don't and so
on
then provide concise and understandable
content this content should be of the
form that users feel like they have
gained something valuable each time they
interact with it you also need to make
sure you practice transparency and
respect your users privacy all of this
can be made possible with the help of
behavioral segmentation or dividing your
audience into groups based on actions
like cart abandonment repeat purchases
page views without conversation and so
on
here we have an example from the popular
food delivery application zomato
now for number two using data to drive
creatives
the combination of the write add images
and their corresponding copies are now
just as important as ad placement and
audience targeting to do it right you
need to use a data driven approach to
the process of creative design you need
to analyze the metrics of the creatives
you're using currently identify what's
going wrong and make corrections or
create new designs to address the issues
and improve non-performing metrics in
fact in organizations like google and
facebook algorithms are being used to
determine what combination of ad copies
and creatives can bring the best
conversion rates and click-through rates
none of which would be possible without
a data-driven approach
next for number three we have to focus
on original research
you need to perform your own research on
latest technologies and trends with data
represented in a creative manner like
with the help of graphics
some of the biggest advantages of having
your own proprietary data enables you to
provide data in a unique angle and makes
it easy to share
moreover with this data being easily
shareable this improves a number of bank
links generated from high authority
websites it would also make you loads of
subscribers
let's now have a look at number four
you need to update your content the
content you have already published will
over a period of time see a decreasing
amount of traffic coming to it which is
why it needs to be updated regularly
with simple tweaks and updates to ensure
it doesn't decay and is refreshed in
google rankings
doing this is also significantly cheaper
than creating a piece of content from
scratch
updates also help increase organic
traffic and to introduce new customers
to your website or content
at number five we have perform guest
blogging
perform guest blogging by having people
with blogs or an audience within your
industry create content for you
first off you can take advantage of
their expertise and drive traffic to
your website
moreover having them to do this
introduces their audience to your brand
this brings you new users you can
eventually turn into leads and then into
customers
here's an example of a guest blogger for
the d-zone website
done properly this can ensure traffic
can be driven to your website
next up at number six you need to use
video
videos are now seen to be one of the
most successful forms of advertising so
why not capitalize on it videos like
tutorials testimonials and behind the
scenes footage can improve your
relationship with your audience and
increase the probability of them
investing in your product or services
they also help humanize your brand
adding doses of genuineness to
interactions with your audience on that
note might i suggest you check out our
video on digital marketing if you're
interested in learning about it i'll add
a link in the live chat
next up at number seven you need to
perform live streams
live streams offer you a free form of
content that doesn't take too long to
create and give significant amounts of
authentic interactions with your
audience
moreover live streams give you a greater
number of impressions than the
traditional types of content that you
can post
next up for number eight making
explainer videos
videos that make complex concepts easier
to understand can be of great help to
your brand or website for starters your
content gets a boost from google thanks
to its preference for video content
this content also improves seo and
marketing opportunities for your website
you can take this one step further and
even create your own video series that
you can put up on youtube or other
learning platforms
now for number nine hosting or joining
podcasts
podcasts give you a platform to interact
with an audience that can return each
week
you could join an existing podcast
series or start your role each of these
methods help improve traffic to your
website and increase brand awareness
involving yourself in established
podcasts within the industry will draw
audience interest to your brand or
product
if the podcaster has a large audience
his or her trust in your brand will
become the audience's trust in your
brand thus bringing you a brand new
audience that can enjoy your content
next up number 10 focusing on local seo
prioritizing the google my business tool
will enable you to manage your brand's
online presence alongside maps and
search results
by focusing on local seo you are making
sure your brand is in front and center
when users search for related terms and
searches it also helps increase your
exposure to local audiences and can
increase the number of leads you can
gain
now for number 11 setting up automated
email campaigns
automating email campaigns can reduce
the amount of time you spent on the task
of manually sending email and increases
the number of emails that you can send
this helps you increase the conversion
rates it can also provide you with more
customization options stuff like a b
testing infographics time zones call to
action buttons and much more
next up number 12 we have test augmented
reality
augmented reality provides additional
personalization that enables greater
interactivity from the users
this by extension increases their
interest in your brand making them more
likely to convert
augmented reality can also give users
the opportunity to preview your product
or services giving them an opportunity
to try it before they can actually
purchase it
here we have an example of an ar
application through which users could be
a part of the launch of the smartphone
oneplus nord
for number 13 you have to use smart
bidding
with smart bidding google uses machine
learning to analyze your data so that it
can optimize your bits in real time with
this you enable google to learn from
past data to optimize your ad spend you
choose an appropriate bid strategy see
how it works out and keep optimizing
finding the right combination can help
you acquire leads and convert them into
customers next up for number 14 you need
to take advantage of your user generated
content
with user generated contents you get
constant updates from your customers and
this tells google that your content is
updated constantly thus helping with
improving your rankings comments and
reviews from users can also improve the
uniqueness of your content
and finally at number 15 we have
gamification
gamifying your content with loyalty
programs and competitions can greatly
improve your audience's engagement with
your brand gamification also encourages
your audience to perform a particular
action like liking sharing or commenting
on content
here's an example of a rewards program
that gives users credits called
star-speaking news as currency at a
number of different locations the more
products you buy from starbucks the more
stars you will learn
before we get on to talking about mobile
marketing let's have a look at some
stats related to mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
revenue in leading b2b organizations so
what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember sms's that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience through multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails sms
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customer and personalized
marketing
in mobile marketing the primary focus is
on the customer want them to increase
brand loyalty give customers special
offers or show them personalized ads
based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying trends with
data by leveraging data different trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an a b test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what doesn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
aso advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine crm or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also crm marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage crm
software see sales increased by 29
sales productivity increased by 34
percent and sales forecast accuracy
increased by 42
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what crm is all about
crm is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crms mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in crm
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns
now although what metric you focus on
entirely depends on your requirements
here are some of the commonly used
metrics
there's customer churn which is
basically customer attrition there's nps
which is a measure of how satisfied your
customers are
best customer retention cost and first
contact resolution rate which is the
percentage of customer support tickets
that get resolved at the first shot
next understanding how different crm
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms there's
salesforce hubspot crm zoho crm
microsoft dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simplylearn dynamics 365 by
microsoft and finally hubspot academy
sales professional credential by hubspot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers say visual images are the most
important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies in western content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good
you might wonder what does designing
have to do with digital marketing plenty
actually if you have an understanding of
designing yourself in the scenario where
graphic designers are unable to bring
your idea to life you could do it
yourself
desiring for yourself what the content
will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creative for the ad
next let's have a look at key concepts
of designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden point rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like adobe photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by coursera introduction to
graphic design by linkedin and
fundamentals of graphic design again by
coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand's social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
where does most of your audience come
from which platform is better suited for
your content those are the questions
that need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like hubspot and
hootsuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like pr
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of b2b
marketers outsource their demanding copy
needs
next it also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more site traffic and
produces brand recall which brings
higher engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
persuades individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website buy a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting
first understanding the customers and
the competition so from the customers
several bits of vital information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of engagement what
kind they dislike and much more
likewise from the competition you can
find out what kind of writing they have
success with what they are doing better
from your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
let's have a look at some certifications
now
here we have the creative copywriter
academy then we have the idm award in
digital copywriting by the institute of
data and marketing
and finally we have american writers and
artists copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 global
email users amounted to 3.9 million by
2023 this is said to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81
smbs rely on email as their primary
customer accusation channel and 80 for
retention
next again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience
in a way email marketing could nurture
the relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at key concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation
emails can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them and each of them can
impact your customer base in a different
manner depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics
to be successful at email marketing it
is absolutely necessary to be
experienced with tools like hubspot and
mailchimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like hubspot
academy email marketing by hubspot then
email and affiliate marketing mastermind
by udemy and finally advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached midway i
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat i'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to simply learn's channel to
stay up to date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number 4 social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 of the
world's population uses social media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of millennials 77.5
percent of generation x and 48.2 percent
of baby boomers are active social media
users
so now let's have a look at social media
marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on youtube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more
then we have analytics experience with
social media marketing tools like buffer
and buzzsumo can help organizations by
providing alerts based on keywords brand
names links domain and much more
among other things it also tracks
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
linkedin learning and finally hootsuite
social marketing certification by
hootsuite
and now for the top three number three
pay-per-click of ppc first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38
ctr on google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in google ads
now let's talk about ppc
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform ppc
for ppc most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine result page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of ppc
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works
each of them have their own but somewhat
similar rules prices restrictions and so
on
then we have google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative players among the
search engines google ads provides
marketers with a sizable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how google ads works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it i'll
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
cpc or course per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as i mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have google ads certifications by
google then advanced pay per click ppc
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have microsoft and
excellence program by microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.6
of all the clicks
and according to google where to buy
plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to hubspot 57
percent of b2b marketers stated that seo
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or seo refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results seo improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of seo technical seo the
technical side of seo like server side
settings site maps
server response code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines
this by extension helps generate traffic
and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both seo and content marketing can
not exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and seo provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
the process of search engine
optimization can only be successful if
there's a combination of both external
link building and internal link
optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability seo must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like moz and google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have google analytics and
google webmaster
google analytics will help with tracking
and reporting website traffic google
webmaster will help track your website
search performance with the help of
google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have seo training course by mers
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have hubspot seo training course
provided by hubspot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like apache spark
tableau and sas can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have google analytics google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website it
records activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component
understanding data visualization would
help with understanding data in a quick
and clean manner it enables brands to
identify emergent trends and to respond
to it quickly
with it the brand story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrative with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by
coursera then we have data analyst
masters program by simply learn and
finally we have micromasters program and
marketing analytics by edx
hey guys welcome to this video on
digital marketing career jobs resume
salary skills roles and responsibilities
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to health care our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved our lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on
digital marketing has the following
types
search engine optimization content
marketing social media marketing search
engine marketing
affiliate marketing
native advertising
marketing automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course
so now let's talk about everything
related to a digital marketer but before
we can get started let's go to a more
familiar setting on where a digital
marketer belongs and strives
the office
now let's start by talking about
who is a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is use digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign
the work doesn't end there though
the digital marketer also needs to
manage the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer
hootsuite and sprout social to measure
and optimize marketing campaigns based
on data obtained from the tools
and finally they're responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing
there's search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine optimization affiliate
marketing
and email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with seo you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of seo has two parts
on page and off page seo let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on page seo
on-page or on-site seo is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or html code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query on-page seo is possible with the
help of keyword research technical
audits on-site optimizations and
enhanced user experiences
next we have off-page seo
off-page or off-site seo refers to
actions taken outside your website to
affect your rankings in search engine
result pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
off-page seo can also be performed with
the help of link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
some of the popular seo tools are moz
google keyword planner semrush and
ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable
relevant and consistent content like
blogs videos infographics and case
studies to bring the attention of a
targeted online audience to the brand's
products and services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions
increased leads
that's what you need to decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas
a buyer persona is a profile created
based on research that represents the
target customer that might enjoy your
products or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a content
management system of your choosing
there are a number of options available
like wordpress mailchimp and squarespace
you will need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that will attract
the attention of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you will need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools
there's buffer
basumo followerwonk and hootsuite
let's now talk about
the next type of digital marketing that
is social media marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build your brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you will need to listen to an engage
with followers analyze results and run
social media advertisements
the process of social media marketing
involves like before you first need to
determine what goal you want to achieve
you need to determine whether you need
increased conversions
email sign ups lead generation or any
other marketing goal
at this stage you'll need to determine
what your audience enjoys the most
you need to find out which files get the
most amount of engagement likes or
shares
then you'll need to research about your
competition within your niche see what
kinds of content they post what content
of theirs receives the most engagement
from their audience and how you can make
similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice
like linkedin facebook instagram twitter
or youtube and start creating marketing
strategies on how to make the most out
of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same
you will then need to create a social
media calendar these are spreadsheets or
applications that will enable you to
plan your social media posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
and finally you will need to keep
testing evaluating and making
adjustments to your marketing campaigns
to finally reach the sweet spot where
you have a perfect social media
marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is hootsuite
tweetdeck sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual
is to determine what goal you want to
achieve with your sem campaign
more leads
conversions
subscriptions
you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against larger ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise and then
start bidding on them to ensure that a
user sees your ad when they search for
that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then
being completely turned off by your
brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments
and finally you will need to make sure
you make regular optimizations
and adjustments based on the data you've
collected and re-target potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are google ads facebook ads
manager
ad role and binge ads just to name a few
next up let's take a look at affiliate
marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a merchant's products
the affiliate usually promotes the
product and earns a commission for each
sale they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations email signups conversions
and subscriptions
here's the process of affiliate
marketing first you will need to decide
the affiliate network you want to choose
the affiliate network is like a favor
for both merchants and affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
as a merchant you will need to set up
specific rules
guidelines
image specifications
commission costs and other details that
an affiliate needs to accept before they
can apply to advertise for you
after this affiliates apply to advertise
on the merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate
and finally the affiliate is given his
or her commission and likewise the
process repeats
itself here are some of the popular
affiliate marketing tools
we have cj affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign
then you decide what kind of emails you
want to send is it a welcome email a
newsletter a lead nurturing email a
re-engagement email that's what you've
got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing
these tools can help you with templates
for emails create email lists track
performance and do much more
you will then need to attract users with
a reason to subscribe to your emails
with attractive opt-in advantages like
exclusive access to sales discounts and
so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that
will attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design
and finally you will need to perform a
or b tests and use analytics to measure
how well your campaign is doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
some popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot sendinblue and marketo
just to name a few
now let's take a look at some digital
marketer carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of glassdoor
first we have digital marketing manager
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately 75 000
per annum in the us
in india
he or she can earn approximately 7 lakh
rupees per annum
next we have seo manager in the united
states an seo manager earns
approximately 62 thousand dollars per
annum
whereas in india an seo manager earns
approximately five lakhs per annum
then we have search engine marketing or
ppc expert a ppc expert in the us earns
approximately seventy four thousand
dollars per annum
whereas in india a ppc expert can earn
approximately four lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the us a social media manager earns
approximately fifty thousand dollars per
annum in india he or she can earn
approximately five lakhs per annum and
finally we have the content marketing
manager a content marketing manager can
earn approximately 65 000
in the united states
in india he or she can earn
approximately 5 lakh rupees per annum
let's have a look at a sample digital
marketer resuming
first off you start off with the usuals
like name address and the other stuff
following this you will need to add a
brief summary of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experience with
in this case this person has two years
of experience in just about every
important type of digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for you give them
links to your socials and then add
experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again
depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for for example for
the role of a sem expert having
experience with google ads and google
analytics is mandatory so that has to be
a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed
having completed the right courses can
have a significant impact on your high
ability
and with that we have come to the end of
this digital marketing full course for
2021 i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will help you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here